Exzellent, Leute. Ich bin ausnahmsweise auch mal wieder am Start.
Ah, und ich habe sogar Wasser aufgefüllt.
Proaktiv, agile, diagonal skaliert.
So, erstmal warten, bis Twitch kapiert hat, dass der Stream on ist.
Bei der Gelegenheit kann ich schon mal meine VM anmachen.
VM. Wir sind ja cool bei der Aussprache.
Immer Pleading Edge.
So, IQ Boost. So sieht es aus.
Das ist enorm nice.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
34 Jahre. Exzellent.
Magst du eigentlich mittlerweile Rust? Früher findest du die Syntax hässlich.
Ich finde die Syntax zum größten Teil immer noch hässlich.
Aber ich mag das vom Ansatz her. Das ist immer was Neues.
Es gibt tausende Sprachen, wo du den Eindruck hast,
das ist irgendeine Mischung aus zum größten Teil bestehenden Sachen.
Und die machen auch nicht wirklich viel neu, außer ein bisschen Syntax.
Rust hat einen ziemlich neuartigen Ansatz mal gehabt.
Die Syntax ist aber gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Der größte Vorteil von Rust ist, dass du die Möglichkeit hast, was zu bauen, was so schnell ist, wie möglich und dabei noch halbwegs memory safe.
Zumindest, solange du die Memory-Safety zu Compilezeit checken kannst.
Die Kombination aus Speed plus Sicherheit gab es in der Kombination nicht.
In der Kombination vor Rust noch nicht.
Also das war wirklich was sehr Innovatives, Neues.
Und genau für diese Anwendung bin ich auch der Meinung, lohnt sich Rust.
Für alles andere, also beinahe Meinung nach für alles andere nicht.
Es sei denn, man möchte dreimal so lange dran entwickeln.
Ich meine, wenn einer Spaß an Rust hat, ich will keinen davon abhalten, das zu machen.
Aber sagen wir mal so, jetzt irgendeinen, keine Ahnung,
einen Webserver-Backend in Rust zu entwickeln,
ist jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt die schnellste Variante.
Und da ist auch fraglich, finde ich, ob Rust so seine Stärken ausspielen kann.
Wenn es natürlich rein um Performance geht und man dabei noch halbwegs Memory-Safe sein will,
dann ist Rust eine tolle Geschichte, vor allem wenn man sich anguckt, wo das Ganze herkommt.
Denn das Ganze hat ja Mozilla erfunden.
Und Mozilla hat das ja unter anderem für Firefox gebaut.
Die haben angefangen, ich glaube, Teile der CSS-Engine waren am Anfang in Rust,
was jetzt mittlerweile alles in Firefox in Rust ist, habe ich keine Ahnung.
Wir können mal gucken, which Firefox parts are in Rust.
Das, okay, oder war, da gibt es keine, gibt es anscheinend keine genaue Antwort drauf.
Ich gehe aber davon aus, dass einiges mittlerweile in Firefox in Rust programmiert ist.
Und wenn man sich überlegt, dass genau für sowas Rust erschaffen wurde, für solche Anwendungsfälle,
dann bietet es sich eben auch an, solche Anwendungsfälle damit umzusetzen, ja.
Was, was so schnell sein muss?
Wie möglich, allerdings mit so sicher, wie es geht, zumindest speichertechnisch so sicher, wie es geht, ja.
Also möglichst ohne großartigen Runtime-Overhead, was Arrays angeht und solche Geschichten.
Also dafür ist Rust gut.
Ich würde nicht unbedingt den nächsten Webservice jetzt mit Rust entwickeln
oder gar Spiele mit Rust entwickeln oder gar Desktop-Anwendungen mit Rust entwickeln.
Ich finde, Rust ist genau für das richtig gut.
Und wofür es gedacht ist, Rust hat mittlerweile so einen, so einen Hype-Train drumherum,
dass irgendwie alles und jeder, und wir gucken uns ja heute eines dieser Tools an, die in, die in Rust entwickelt wurden, ja.
Also, das hat so ein bisschen den Trend, so eine, so eine, der so Fahrt aufgenommen,
dass gefühlt jetzt irgendwie alles und jedes Ding in Rust neu entwickelt wird, ja.
Es gibt Grep in Rust neu implementiert, LS in Rust neu implementiert.
Es gibt eigentlich, was dir einfällt, gibt es irgendein Projekt, wo irgendeiner versucht hat,
das in Rust nachzubauen, da bin ich der Meinung, das ist nur so semi-sinnvoll, ja.
Weil ganz im Ernst, wir gucken uns heute, ich kann ja schon ein bisschen Spoiler,
wir gucken uns heute ein Projekt an, das nennt sich, ich denke mal, Biome oder Biome, wahrscheinlich Biome, Jazz.
Das ist ein Formator für, für JavaScript.
Und das ist halt so ein Ding, ganz ehrlich, das ist jetzt eigentlich nix, wo ich pauschal so an Rust denken würde davon,
wenn ich sowas programmieren will.
Weil, es ist eigentlich ziemlich egal, ob das Ding jetzt super memory safe ist und, äh, ganz furchtbar secure.
Es ist ein Formator für JavaScript-Code, das ist nicht so wirklich relevant an der Stelle.
Ähm, die Performance ist relevant, aber die könnte man wahrscheinlich auch mit sehr vielen anderen Sprachen erreichen,
wo man eventuell einen, ja, zumindest spürbaren, äh, Entwicklungsgeschwindigkeits-Boost hätte.
Also, ich bin da nicht so ganz davon überfordert.
Also, ich bin da nicht so ganz davon überfordert. Also, ich bin da nicht so ganz davon überfordert.
Also, ich bin da nicht so ganz davon überzeugt, moin!
Ich bin da nicht so ganz davon überzeugt, von diesem Trend, Alles und jedes Ding unbedingt in Rust neu programmieren zum müssen,
aber ich find's auf jeden Fall gut, weil eine Sache hat Rust, und die find ich auch sehr nice,
Rust hat mittlerweile ein ziemlich großes Ökosystem,
und es gibt auch die ein oder anderen Sachen, die man von Rust findet,
die es sooo, zumindest nicht so oft für andere Programmiersprachen gibt.
An Libraries zum Beispiel, es gibt für, es gibt für Rust zum Beispiel eine relativ gute WebRTC-Libre,
das gibt es für kaum andere programmiersprachen und der vorteil des
in russ zu machen ist interop mit anderen programmiersprachen ist easy
ähnlich ähnlich easy wie c letztendlich machst du es über mit c funktions
aufrufen und es ist schnell und es hat ein gutes ökosystem die beste web rtc
library gibt es meiner meinung nach immer noch also für klein also für
beckern seite dann gibt es meine meiner meinung nach immer noch in gold und die
web rtc was ist auch quasi ein klohn der go library aber interop aus anderen
programmiersprachen ist mit rast um längen einfacher dadurch dass er das
einfach als c funktionen exportieren aufrufen kannst als mit go mit go c
interop und übergreifend das geht das ist aber schon eklig an vielen stellen
so ich war auch kurz package updates was ist das was web rtc oder rast oder bio
rast oder bio rast oder bio rast oder bio
oder ja dass wir gucken uns das heute an ich bin mal gespannt ob das das kann
was ich will weil ich habe schon gesehen dass weltfalls nur bisher experimental
oder sowas in der richtung unterstützt werden deswegen wollte ich mir das
heute mal angucken ja zur übung ich sage ja gar nichts ich will ja keiner von
abhalten irgendwas in rast neu zu programmieren soll ja jeder machen wie
er will ist schon in ordnung man lernt auch was bei 95 prozent was ich
proklamiere
ist keinerlei mehrwert drin einfach nur weil es mich interessiert da ist überhaupt
nichts dagegen zu sagen wobei ich finde dass man nicht alles
zwangsläufig unbedingt in rast neu programmieren muss zum beispiel wenn
rewrite von ls aber das wirklich gebraucht gibt es ja gibt es ja mehrere
es gibt extra und wie ist das andere auch irgendwie so ähnlich gibt ein paar
rewrites von ls mehrwertig und dann gibt es ja auch noch ein paar mehrwertige
rewrites mit mehr features in rast das hätte ich persönlich nicht gebraucht aber
immerhin schön wenn das einer machen will und der spaß daran dass du entwickeln
überhaupt kein ding ja das ist alles schön und gut kann jeder mit seiner zeit
machen was er will aber das ist was wo ich dabei bin das hätte es nicht gebraucht
und ich bin sogar der meinung gerade bei diesen super standard tools bei sowas
wie ls und grepp und sowas in der richtung finde ich fast schon kontraproduktiv
was anderes zu verwenden als die standard tools
weil die dinge haben immer so ein paar kleine sachen an die die dich die mehr
können ja an die dich dann gewöhnt oder aber an sachen die sie eben anders
können als die original tools ja dann hast du beispielsweise willst ls
machten und bei deinem lokalen tool ist das h muss groß geschrieben werden dass
es funktioniert und dann gibt und dann gewöhnt sich daran und schreibst auf dem
server auch große da ist die ausgabe anders ja oder du gewöhnst dich an
irgendwas was es gibt und gibt dann ein ls- bruch und stellt das auch eine ist das etwas was das gibt und gibt es ein ls-bruch und stellst du das auch nee ist das ein absolutes Tool!
funktioniert ja nicht. Ja klar, weil das auf dem Server
kein Rust-LS ist.
Also mit so Standard-Tools, muss ich ehrlich sagen,
ist zumindest meine Meinung,
halte ich mich zurück
mit Replacement-Sachen.
Also ich habe beispielsweise, es gibt ja zig Ersatz,
ja,
Rewritten, AWK,
Zed, Grep,
alles mögliche,
Find, LS,
alles mögliche gibt es da,
gibt es da Rewritten in Rust und sonst wie.
Ich verwende nichts davon. Ich habe mal eine Zeit
lang extra verwendet,
benutze ich aber auch nicht mehr. Einfach,
weil man sich zu sehr dran gewöhnt
und dann im Zweifelsfall, wenn man mal auf dem Server
unterwegs ist, irgendeinen Mist eingibt.
Gerade bei diesen super
Basic-Standard-Tools
muss das nicht unbedingt sein.
Finde ich. Was möchte
der mir hier eigentlich sagen? Ist meine Festplatte fast
voll oder wie?
Ah ja, tatsächlich.
51 Gig
available. Warum ist das so voll?
Muss ich mal ein paar Docker
Docker-Images?
Was war das? Docker-Prune?
System-Prune-A-A?
Aber das war nicht so viel.
Okay.
Was genau? Warum ist das so voll?
Was ist da alles am Start?
Was ist da
am Start? Ich lösche dieses Video
jetzt mal, weil es jedes Mal für
Irritationen im Chat
sagt, wenn einer den Titel liest.
Das ist ein altes YouTube-Video.
Weil ich runtergeladen habe von meinem Channel.
Der Titel ist...
Zumindest ist es kein Clickbait-Titel.
Es geht aber nicht um
echte Mädels unterm Dach, sondern um Gemälde
von meinem Opa in dem Video.
Das werde ich jetzt mal löschen.
Warum ist... Guck mal hier.
Cache. Cache ist...
Okay. Wir clearen einfach
mal unseren Cache.
Wie war das? Pack Cache?
Pack Cache minus R0
oder so. RK?
So.
Guck mal. 58 Gig haben wir
saved. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das
den Yay Cache auch...
Nein. Macht es nicht.
Yay. Clear. Cache. Wie geht das?
Was?
Da gibt es doch irgendeinen...
Minus CC. Okay.
Zack.
Do you want to remove all files from Cache? Yes.
Database. Do you want to
remove unused repositories?
Äh.
No.
Do you want to remove
from Cache? Yes.
So.
Und jetzt haben wir auf einen Schlag
einfach mal 80 Gig
wiedergekriegt. Einfach nur Package
Build Cache. Nice.
Kommt jetzt durch Crowdsign eigentlich das Jahr?
Ja.
Ja. Bestimmt.
Das Jahr... Nächstes Jahr ist
das Jahr des Linux-Desktops.
Genauso wie übrigens dieses Jahr
und letztes Jahr und das Jahr drauf.
Das bezweifle ich sogar.
Dass die Performance nennenswert
steigt bei solchen großen Sachen.
Ja gut. Kann schon sein.
Kommt drauf an, welche Features
man verwendet.
Aber gerade diese Tools, die
sind schon relativ schnell.
Gerade Grep ist wirklich schnell.
Ja, ich weiß. Es gibt...
Was gibt's? Silver-Searcher und alle möglichen
Sachen, die Grep dann nochmal ein bisschen schneller
machen. Aber ich bezweifle,
dass es so einen großen Unterschied macht.
Jedes Jahr ist das Jahr des Linux-Desktops.
Ja, so seit
19... Äh, nicht seit 19... Also, seit 2000...
Also, 2006, würde ich sagen.
Ganz ehrlich, 2006,
7, 8, 9...
Das waren für mich die coolsten Jahre
des Linux-Desktops.
Nicht wirklich, weil es da super den Durchbruch
gab oder sowas in der Richtung.
Sondern, ich hab's ja schon oft gesagt,
weil das die Zeit war, wo es Ubuntu
mit Compets gab, beziehungsweise
Ubuntu mit Barrel. Barrel war ein Compets-Fork.
Und da konntest du ganz tolle Sachen
machen. Ja, da hattest du Fenster, die
gewackelt haben, Fenster, die abgebrannt
sind, Würfel auf dem Desktop.
Alles, alles abgedrehtes
Zeug. Das war für mich, da hat man
gedacht, die Zukunft ist
jetzt, äh...
Woher weißt du, dass ich Geburtstag
habe?
Leak? Oder wie?
Oder was?
Massive Leak. Aber das stimmt!
Ich bin jetzt 40.
Stellt euch vor, ich hab da wirklich
keinen Bock drauf.
Soll ich mal kurz was gucken auf dem zweiten Bildschirm?
Ja, das erzählen die Leute
auch schon, seit ich 27 war.
Da hab ich mich angehört wie 16.
Ist halt so. Ja, offiziell
Boomer.
Ist Linux auf dem Firetelevie auch ein Desktop?
Äh, äh...
Da kann man sich jetzt drüber
streiten. Ich würd sagen,
nee. Das zählt nicht wirklich.
Desktop ist für mich auf dem Desktop
PC.
Oder auf dem Notebook.
Oder halt irgendwas, wo man normal am
Schreibtisch sitzt und dran arbeitet.
Nicht wirklich jetzt als
reines GUI auf dem
Fernseher. Also, für mich ist
ein Raspberry Pi mit Kodi drauf auch
kein Desktop.
Hab ich jetzt eigentlich alle Updates gemacht?
Glaub schon, oder?
Hab ich alle Updates gemacht?
Okay, nice.
NWG Look gibt es
nicht. Okay.
Dann wird das jetzt uninstalled.
Wenn es das nicht gibt.
Wette mit euch, das wurde einfach
verschoben.
Jawoll, ein jetzt offizielles
Package, nice. Okay.
Ja.
Wo bin ich denn stehen geblieben?
Ich muss gerade auf dem zweiten Bildschirm was gucken.
Ich war gerade etwas abgelenkt.
Ja, ich hab mich über Rust ausgelassen.
Und...
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was ich
extrem lustig fand?
Oh, Moment. Mein Headset
backt rum.
Sack.
Ich glaube, ich muss das mal
entknoten wieder.
So. Übrigens, wisst ihr, was ich extrem lustig fand?
Und zwar, ich hab gelesen, dass bei Olympia
das Pferd eines
der Dressurreiter, die da
antreten.
Wisst ihr, wie das heißt?
Das heißt Bluetooth.
Ist ja endlich mal ein guter Name für so ein Viech, oder?
Ja, ich würde mein Pferd vielleicht nicht unbedingt
Bluetooth nennen, aber es ist wenigstens mal ein guter Name.
Weiß nicht, wie die Viecher
sonst so heißen, aber garantiert nicht Bluetooth.
Das fand ich geil.
Approved.
Der Name von mir.
Was benutzt du für die VM?
VMA Workstation.
Ist das?
OMWare.
Es ist nicht Virtual Box.
Und ich hab auch nicht
Windows unter Linux laufen,
sondern ich hab Linux in Windows laufen.
Mit VMA Workstation.
Chat, bevor wir anfangen,
aber wieso?
Du meinst, warum ich das überhaupt mache,
oder warum ich es ausgerechnet so mache?
Also ich mein, warum ich es überhaupt mache,
ist relativ schnell beantwortet.
Weil es Sachen gibt, die man unter Linux besser machen kann,
und Sachen gibt, die man unter Windows besser machen kann.
Das ist eigentlich relativ einfach,
kurz und klagig beantwortet.
Und ich mach das, was man unter Windows besser machen kann,
unter Windows,
und das, was man unter Linux besser machen kann,
unter Linux.
Zum Beispiel, Zeug programmieren,
generell über Windows.
Und ich mach das, was man unter Windows besser machen kann,
programmieren, generell rumbasteln,
Sachen ausprobieren, Elektronikkram,
also alle möglichen Sachen, die mit irgendeinem bisschen was
mit Technikkram zu tun haben, programmieren,
sonst was, in der Richtung
alles unter Linux.
Wenn's um
Gaming geht,
oder auch hier streamen,
oder Thumbnails für YouTube machen,
Videos schneiden und sowas mach ich unter Windows.
Gibt's da Tricks bei der Performance?
Ja, also
je nachdem, was du vorhast.
Manche Sachen werden in der VRM nie schnell sein.
Zum Beispiel
wirst du in der VRM nie
Hardware beschleunigtes
Videodecoding haben.
Ja, also wenn ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel
mal ein YouTube Video anmache,
da wirst du sehen,
mach mal irgendein Video von mir an.
Ah.
Aber hier irgendwas, was ein bisschen
wo sich ein bisschen was
bewegt drinne.
Ah, hier Battlefield, ok.
Also, wenn ich das jetzt hochstelle,
auf 1044p,
siehste,
das ist doch schon relativ hohe CPU-Auslastung.
Ja.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen
weniger, weil ich hier rüber switche,
oder die grafische Ausgabe ausmachen kann.
Aber man sieht schon, also allein schon
das Videodecoden,
wobei ich wette, der ist ziemlich schlau,
der lässt das Videodecoden einfach,
allein schon das Videodecoden braucht halt,
ja, ich würd mal sagen,
den CPU-Kern fast schon komplett.
Oh.
Leicht.
Ne, ja.
Zumindest ist es relativ hoch.
Unter Windows würde das Ganze so gut wie
Null zu Buche schlagen,
was CPU-Last angeht.
Wir können das jetzt übrigens auch übertreiben,
wenn man sagt, 4K-Video, irgendein 4K-Video,
also irgendein Ultra-HD-Video oder sowas.
Sondern wenn ich das hier abspiele auf
noch höher, guck,
da geht hier die Auslastung von dem Ding
richtig rauf, ja.
Ja, da muss ich mal
ein bisschen was bewegen, dass das funktioniert.
So. Warum Swap?
Warum nicht Swap?
Also ihr seht, das geht richtig hoch.
Das wird man beispielsweise nie ordentlich hinkriegen
in der VM.
Das GPU-Decoding funktioniert von Videos,
weil das Ding hat schlicht und ergreifend
keinen Zugriff auf meine Grafikkarte.
Das muss das über die CPU machen.
Aber für alles andere,
was nicht so Spezial-Hardware-
Access braucht, funktioniert das wunderbar.
Es gehen sogar 3D-Geschichten
solange das ein bisschen älteres OpenGL
verwendet, eigentlich relativ gut.
Auch gar nicht so langsam.
Aber für irgendwelche 3D-Sachen ist das
wirklich nicht gedacht. Es geht, es geht, ja.
Also man kann beispielsweise hier
irgendeinen
Tessellation-Benchmark oder hier
Juni, wie heißt dieses Ding hier?
Juni Engine Heaven.
Das kann man auch in der VM starten.
Und
das funktioniert dann auch ganz brauchbar in der VM.
Solange man halt
keine...
Was verwendet was, guck hier,
das...
Das ist okay in der VM.
Das ist jetzt alles
andere irgendwie als, dass ich
jetzt ganz 3D-Zeug verwenden würde, aber es funktioniert.
Solange das
auf eine Grafik-API zugreift,
die unterstützt wird von
VMWare. Aber das ist jetzt nicht das,
wofür ich es hauptsächlich verwenden würde.
Es geht, ja, aber...
Es geht auch
besser.
Legst du jetzt deine CPU ein...
Ach, gibt es dazu Neuigkeiten?
Das letzte, was ich gehört habe, ist, dass Interlink
ein Firmware-Update rausbringen will im August.
Ja.
So, und
der Tipp ist,
wenn man seine VM...
Wenn man ordentlich schnell in seiner VM arbeiten
will, ist, einfach
nichts...
Also nichts benutzen, was
darauf angewiesen ist, dass man
irgendwelche 3D-Acceleration-
Fichten braucht, ja?
Also sobald da irgendwelche
Composite-Window-Manager reinkommen,
die irgendwelchen Spezialkram machen,
so halbtransparente
Fenster-Animationen und sonst was,
da ist es manchmal ein bisschen ruckelig.
Wobei man auch tatsächlich sagen muss, ja,
also die neuesten
Distros, wenn man sich anguckt, egal ob es jetzt
Ubuntu ist oder ob es
Mint ist oder sowas, die funktionieren
alle wunderbar in der VM.
Ich glaube, ich glaube das
Wichtigste ist, dass man eben die passenden Sachen macht.
Ich persönlich mag eh gar nichts
an Desktops,
beziehungsweise an UIs
unter Linux, außer i3.
i3 ist halt
so minimalistisch, da kann eigentlich nichts
ruckeln. Und ansonsten
eine Sache, die VMs
richtig gut kann, ist CPU.
Ihr werdet kaum
einen Performance-Unterschied
feststellen zwischen, wie man ja eindeutig hier auch
sieht an dieser High-Performance-
Anwendung,
wie man hier sieht, CPU-Auslastung.
Was eine VM richtig gut kann, ist
wenn man update... Echt, hast du mal
einen Link? Hast du mal einen Link?
Vielleicht wird es auch Zeit
für einen AMD-Rechner, Leute.
Ich meine, mein Rechner ist schon
eineinhalb
Jahre.
Wird mal wieder
Zeit.
Also, soweit ich weiß,
gibt es zwei Probleme.
Es gibt ein paar der alten
CPUs, die dieses...
ja, diesen Defekt
haben.
Und es gibt ein paar...
Also, es gibt zwei Defekte, so wie ich das in dem Video
vom Auer verstanden
hab. Von der Bauer.
Es gibt zwei Defekte.
Und zwar ein, der
fabrikseitig drin ist und dazu führt, dass die CPU
relativ schnell kaputt geht.
Und einen anderen,
der wohl am...
Ja, einer
der in einer
programmierten Firmware liegt.
Und wenn man beides in Kombination hat,
ergänzt sich das natürlich noch.
Der Acht-Auer, genau.
Dann ergänzt sich das natürlich noch
und es geht doppelt so schnell und dreimal so schnell kaputt.
Oh, Intel CPU...
Weil ansonsten habe ich da noch nichts Neues zugehört.
Hat Heising was Neues
geschrieben?
Ja. Zweiter Achter, gestern.
Fehlerbehaftet Raptor Lake CPUs.
Intel gewährt zwei extra Jahre Garantie.
Und von Alterungsverlänger...
Ja, Garantiezeit ist...
Eigentlich ist es halt scheiße, wenn dein Rechner
einfach kaputt ist und dann erst mal...
Na gut, ich hab ja meinen zweiten noch.
Okay.
BIOS-Updates für neue Micro-Codes.
Ja, okay, das ist das zweite
von zwei Problemen. Das erste war
die fertigungseitige Sache.
Ja, genau. Hier, das ist das
Oxidationsproblem.
Das bei manchen Core i13...
Ich hab halt einen der ersten
13.900K.
Ja, aber wir könnten davon betroffen sein.
Intel konnte bestätigen, dass die betroffenen
Prozessoren...
Das ist mir doch scheißegal.
Ich will wissen, ob meine CPU betroffen ist.
Ne, glauben kannst du denen eh nichts.
Das ist halt so für'n Arsch.
Ja gut, ich gehe davon aus,
die wissen es einfach nicht.
Ich glaube, die wissen es einfach nicht.
Was mich interessieren würde ist,
wie wahrscheinlich ist es überhaupt,
dass man es merken wird.
Als normaler User.
Ja.
Wo der PC zum größten Teil im Idle läuft
und irgendwie ab und zu mal
nen Game.
Wie wahrscheinlich ist es, dass man es überhaupt
hier merken wird?
Weiß man halt nicht, ja.
Also ich persönlich bin nicht so erpicht drauf,
meinen Rechner aufzuschrauben und eine neue CPU reinzumachen.
Auf der anderen Seite wäre das
auch nicht so wild...
Ach, er wieder hier.
Ja, das kenne ich schon.
Jaja. Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Da bin ich mal gespannt,
was da rauskommt. Ähm...
Ja, aber ganz ehrlich,
ich wäre blöde, wenn ich jetzt einfach
im Vorfeld schon meinen Rechner austausche,
ohne dass es was ist, ja.
Ich meine, die Chancen sind, würde ich mal sagen,
gar nicht so gering, dass ich meinen Rechner
einfach in eineinhalb Jahren oder so
austausche oder in zwei Jahren,
keine Ahnung, oder in zweieinhalb Jahren
und bis dahin einfach nichts davon
bemerkt haben werde.
Wo bin ich denn gerade stehen geblieben?
Ich wollte vorhin...
Ach, zu VMs wollte ich noch was erzählen.
Chat, ich habe keine Ahnung,
wie ich gerade drauf komme.
Es ist mir ein komplettes Rätsel, aber
manchmal
sitze ich so vor dem Rechner,
gerade wenn ich irgendwie den Stream an habe,
manchmal sitze ich so vor dem Rechner
und dann kommt mir sowas
in den Kopf, so random, einfach Sachen,
die schon Jahre her sind.
Erinnert sich noch irgendeiner an
Dicks Out for Harambee?
Den Affe, den sie erschossen haben
im Zoo? Ich weiß nicht,
keine Ahnung, wie ich da jetzt drauf komme.
Kann sich noch einer daran erinnern?
Wahrscheinlich.
Ich will jetzt nicht danach, ich will jetzt nicht
danach googeln, ja.
2014, ja, kann sein.
Das ist, das ist ewig her.
Dicks Out for Harambee.
War das nicht sogar
im August irgendwann?
Ah, ne, im Mai. Okay.
Ich habe gerade nachgeguckt, im zweiten Rechner.
Im Mai war das.
Dicks Out for Harambee.
Der konnte halt gar nichts für, ne?
Kommt nichts wegen TOS.
Ja, ich will trotzdem nicht nach
Dicks Out googeln.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob da nichts ohne
TOS kommt. So.
Ich wollte noch was zum Thema Virtualisierung
sagen.
Chatge, glaube ich zumindest.
Oh Patrick, danke schön für den Sub.
Ich habe sie gar nicht gesehen. Pog.
Aber hat Valve Gaming
unter Linux mit dem Steam Deck nicht
salonfähig gemacht?
Ein bisschen. Mehr als es
vorher war, aber ich meine,
es hat sich in den letzten Jahren enorm viel
entwickelt. Aber es gibt immer noch Sachen, die nicht
funktionieren halt. Zum größten Teil Anti-Cheat
Geschichten. Also wenn du Fortnite spielen willst, hast du gelitten.
Wenn du Rainbow Six spielen willst, hast du gelitten.
Wie es bei Apex aussieht, weiß ich nicht.
Wie es bei LOL aussieht, bin ich mir
aktuell nicht sicher. Ich glaube aber, es geht auch nicht.
Also da hast du immer noch Probleme.
Ein Großteil der Sachen funktioniert,
ja. Aber es ist immer noch nicht so gut
wie unter Windows. Also man kann immer noch nicht sagen, ey,
ich bin mir sicher, wenn ich das
jetzt, wenn was Neues rauskommt.
Und ich will das jetzt
ausprobieren,
dann geht das einfach.
Wenn Fire TV kein
Desktop ist, dann Steam Deck auch
kein Desktop. Ne, ist es auch nicht.
Ich würde auch nicht sagen, dass Steam Deck
als Desktop zählt, ja.
Aber vieles von den Technologien,
die mit und um Steam Deck entstanden
sind, kannst du auch auf dem Desktop verwenden.
Ja, Proton zum Beispiel
und das ganze,
wie heißt das andere, dieser DirectX
zu Vulkan Zeug und
was es da alles gibt.
Ja, aber noch
als letztes mal eine Sache
zum Thema Virtualisierung. Also,
ich mache unter Windows das, was unter
Windows besser funktioniert und unter Linux das, was unter Linux
am besten funktioniert. Und der einzige
Tipp, den man geben kann hier zu
es ist langsam in der VM ist,
nicht so viele
Sachen verwenden, die irgendwie 3D Acceleration
brauchen. Ja, ich habe auch ein bisschen was. Ihr seht
ja, der Hintergrund, mein Hintergrund ist leicht
transparent. Also wenn ihr genau guckt,
könnt ihr den Pepo hier hinten durchgucken.
Also ein bisschen Transparenz habe ich, aber
es hält sich wirklich sehr in Grenzen.
Wenn man jetzt beispielsweise
Wayland verwenden will, hast du komplett
verloren in der VM, funktioniert überhaupt nicht richtig.
Und wenn man eben
auch
modernere, andere sowieso, Composite
Window Manager
verwenden will, die überall irgendwelche
halbtransparenten
Blur-Hintergründe haben und Animationen
und so, da kann das teilweise schon ein bisschen hakelig sein.
Übrigens Wayland, das heißt nicht, dass Wayland
gar nicht funktioniert. Wayland in
manchen Konstellationen funktioniert,
aber so Sachen wie Hyperland und sowas kannst du
vergessen und Sway funktioniert auch nicht richtig.
Also, Wayland
in der VM ist von Arsch, deswegen ist das Ding auch immer noch
auf X, wie man hier sieht.
Oder Fast Fetch,
wie das die coolen Leute heute verwenden.
Steht das überhaupt, dass das X-based ist?
Weiß man gar nicht, gell?
Steht da irgendwas von X?
Ah, also immer. So.
Und wenn man die Sachen verwendet, die von der VM
gut kann, nämlich CPU-Performance,
dann ist das überhaupt kein Problem.
Was auch enorm hilft natürlich ist,
wenn man dem Ding ordentlich CPUs und RAM
gibt. Ich meine, VM hat 24
GB RAM und
8 CPU-Kerne.
Das ist mehr als mancher
normale Nicht-VM-Rechner
hat. Ach, hier steht
X11, genau. Die 24
GB RAM, die sind
komplett Oversized, so viel braucht man nicht.
Man kommt ohne Probleme auch mit 8 GB RAM aus.
Je nachdem, was man starten will, ja?
Wenn ich jetzt 3 Jetbrains
Java-based
IDEs starten will,
dann ist es vielleicht
nicht so gut mit 8 GB RAM.
Aber ansonsten, guckst du auf einen Schlager,
ist 700 weg. Aber ansonsten
gar kein Ding.
Jo.
Und es ist in der VM überhaupt kein Problem.
Funktioniert wunderbar. Und was auch
nice ist, ist, wenn man das auf
einen zweiten Windows-Desktop schiebt. Guckt, ich hab das hier
auf Desktop 2, hab ich die VM.
Auf Desktop 1 hab ich das Windows-Zeug.
Und wenn ich jetzt
das hier im Fullscreen hab, kann ich quasi
zwischen dem ersten Desktop
mit Windows und dem zweiten Desktop
mit der VM im Fullscreen wechseln.
Was sehr praktisch ist, weil
bessere Interaktionen gibt es nicht.
Und warum ich Linux
unter Windows virtualisiere
und nicht etwa
Windows unter Linux, liegt
einfach daran, weil es einfacher ist.
Und für meinen Anwendungszweck
besser funktioniert.
Ja, hab ich.
Hab ich aber nicht komplett
fertig gemacht. Und das hat auch ein paar
Dinger, die, die waren schon ein bisschen
doof. Ja, zum Beispiel, dass out of the box
copy-paste nicht funktioniert. Da musst du dich um extra Lösungen
für kümmern. Ja, auch mit
Sound hat man Lacks
und Probleme. Man merkt, dass das
nicht so hundertprozentig dafür gemacht ist.
Aber es geht. Ja.
So. Da gucken wir uns das Ganze
doch mal an. Die Musik ist übrigens viel zu laut.
Fällt mir grad auf. So ist gut.
So, da gucken wir uns das Ganze
doch mal an.
Falls ich jetzt noch irgendwas vergessen hab,
schreibt's mal in Chat. Ich hab ein paar Sachen
angefangen, dann Zeit getrackt und dann wieder
vergessen. Planst du dir
irgendwann ein OLED-Bildschirm zu kaufen? Ja.
Sogar schon relativ bald.
Sobald ich mich auf irgendwas
festgelegt hab, was die passende Kombination
hat aus nicht zu groß,
weil ich sitz relativ nah davor. Ich hab lieber
zwei Rechner und zwei Bildschirme.
Anstatt irgendwie ein Rechner mit Riesenbildschirm.
Also einer, der
nicht zu groß ist.
Für meinen Schreibtisch.
Und
einen OLED, der
auch gleichzeitig noch
eine hohe Bildwiederholrate
hat.
Also was, was quasi
das Beste aus beiden
Welten irgendwie vereint.
Aktuell hab ich tatsächlich
noch, auch wenn das ziemlich oldschool erscheinen mag,
einen 1080p Bildschirm
mit 240Hz.
Das find ich einfach angenehmer.
Wenn man irgendwelche Sachen
spielt. Also mir ist
Bildwiederholrate
und Frames
wichtiger als hohe Auflösung.
Wobei man ja sagen muss,
bevor jetzt einer kommt, ja, das eine hat mit dem
anderen nicht zwangsläufig was zu tun.
Man kann auch ohne Probleme, wenn man V-Sync ausschaltet,
auf 60Hz-Monitoren
mit 300 FPS spielen.
Oder werden halt Frames gedroppt.
Aber am besten ist es natürlich,
wenn sowohl viel FPS
gerendert werden und der Bildschirm oft
crashen kann.
Dann hat man logischerweise den niedrigsten
Input-Lag.
Und niedrigsten Delay.
Und gerade bei Kameraschwenks und sowas
merkt man halt den Unterschied zwischen
60 oder 120 sofort.
Aber ich will nicht zwei
Bildschirme in einem.
Michael Fünftspiel, ja, danke schön für den Sub.
Ich will zwei Bildschirme an zwei Rechnern
nebeneinander. Ich will keinen 34 Zoll
Ultrawide. Ja sowas,
27 Zoll, 27 Zoll
in einem normalen Formfaktor
gut, ja.
27 Zoll OLED 240Hz+.
Das ist was, damit könnte ich leben.
Dafür würde ich auch ein bisschen
Kohle ausgeben.
Und ich mein,
am Rechner soll es nicht scheitern.
Das ist ein 13.900K.
Mal gucken wie lang noch.
Und
ne
4090 Ti, ne
nicht Ti, normale
4090, weil ich zu viel Geld hatte.
Also
die macht schon
die hat schon genug Power
dafür, ja.
Kannst du einen guten Lötkolben empfehlen?
Ich kann dir meine
Lötstation empfehlen, die ich hab.
Die ich mir auch jederzeit wieder
kaufen würde. Einen einzelnen Lötkolben
kann ich dir nicht
empfehlen. Also die Dinger kenn ich,
die werden auch immer mal gerne empfohlen.
Vor allem gibt es da
Custom Firmware auf GitHub.
Man kann sich überlegen, wir sind im Jahr
2024 angekommen, da flasht man
auch mit Custom Firmware seinen Lötkolben.
Machen die Spitzen einen großen Unterschied? Ja.
Also je nachdem was du machen
willst, ist es ein riesen Unterschied, ob du ne
kleine längliche Spitze hast oder
ne bisschen breitere und sonst wie.
Also gerade wenn du ein bisschen was größeres
löten möchtest,
also beispielsweise du willst irgendwelche
Pinheader
anlöten und du machst das mit so ner
ganz kleinen feinen
Lötkolben Spitze, kannst du vergessen,
es wird nicht schnell genug heiß.
Da hältst du das ne halbe Minute dran,
bis das Lötzinn fließt.
Kaum machst du ein bisschen dickeren Lötkolben
Spitze, geht das ohne Probleme.
Was übrigens auch einen riesen Unterschied macht,
wenn man
Probleme hat, dass die Stelle heiß wird,
wenn man ein bisschen Lötzinn an den
Lötkolben vorher dran macht, dann gibt es
besseres Kontakt zu der Stelle.
Also bessere Wärmeübertragung zu der
Stelle, wo man eigentlich löten will.
Was ich so usen tue, kann ich dir zeigen,
wenn du die Seite dran hältst,
dann hast du wahrscheinlich das
gleiche Problem, was ich gerade beschrieben habe,
weil wenn du die Seite dran hältst, dann hast du
mehr Fläche und es wird
schneller warm. Wenn du die Spitze
dran hältst, ist es halt zu klein.
Ich benutze in der Regel nur
zwei verschiedene Lötkolben Spitzen.
Ich habe noch ein paar Zwischengrößen.
Ich habe so ne ganz kleine, feine Spitze
und die Standardspitze, die drauf ist.
Die Standardspitze benutze ich für 90%
und für irgendwelchen kleinen
Scheiß.
Mir fällt jetzt noch nicht mal ein Beispiel
ein, ein gescheites.
Für irgendwelchen kleinen Scheiß.
Hier im Stream habe ich mal die kleine Spitze
verwendet, ich weiß aber gar nicht mehr für was.
Irgendwas richtig
kleines, popliches.
Was haben wir denn hier mal gelötet?
Sowas richtig kleines, abartiges.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was das genau gewesen ist.
Da habe ich die kleine Spitze benutzt, ansonsten gar nicht.
Also was ich habe, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Guck mal, Amazon.
Ich habe eine
Ersa Icon Nano.
Pico Nano.
Die by the way
nicht so teuer ist, wenn man
da mal ordentlich nachguckt.
Weil so viel habe ich nicht dafür bezahlt.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Ich guck mal, was ich dafür bezahlt habe.
Das ist glaube ich nicht wirklich
der normale Preis,
was da bei Amazon steht.
Ich habe,
hä?
Ich suche nach Ersa und finde
Ah, wegen Razer, oh Gott.
Amazon versucht,
ähm, ich finde
Rasierklingen, weil der denkt, dass Ersa und Razer
irgendwie ähnlich ist.
Ja, Icon Nano. 2018
habe ich die gekauft.
Hat gekostet
193 Euro.
Okay, kann doch
mittlerweile der normale Preis sein.
Schauen wir mal.
Gucken wir mal bei
Geizhals oder bei wo auch immer.
Ne, okay, es geht
doch ein bisschen günstiger.
Und die sieht auch ein bisschen anders aus, jetzt sehe ich
gerade. Das scheint eine zweite Variante
davon zu sein, weil meine ist
vorne Silber.
Und nicht
komplett Schwarz.
Das scheint eine neuere Variante davon zu
sein. Vielleicht haben sie sich
gedacht, okay, wir
machen die Front einfach
andere Farbe und verlangen 80 Euro mehr.
Das wäre eigentlich richtiger
High-IQ-Move, oder?
Und was das Gute an dieser Lötstation ist,
ich zeige euch das mal.
Löten.
Äh,
Aufwachen-Stream, Aufwachen-Stream,
Hackerman.
Wo ist der Lötchamp?
Wir haben das doch noch gar nicht allzu lange Zeit,
wo wir den Lötchamp gemacht haben.
Ich glaube, die Vorschau ist einfach
hier. Lötchamp mit
Custom-PCB. Hier haben wir
Kleinscheiß gelötet, genau.
Da habe ich die, da habe ich die kleine
Spitze verwendet.
Wo wird denn hier gelötchamped überhaupt?
Hier wird gelötchamped, guck.
Ich will dir, wollte dir eigentlich noch was zeigen.
Oh, hatte ich nicht.
Oh, ich kack nur, ich hatte es nicht im Bild.
Alter, wie dumm.
Hier. So.
Und was da halt, was da halt richtig gut ist,
Ja.
Da, okay, das ist doch die dicke Spitze.
Was da halt richtig gut ist an dem Lötkolben, leider
sieht man das in dem
Video nicht, weil ich so
nah rangezoomt habe, dass ihr was erkannt habt.
Was
richtig, was richtig nice ist,
an der Lötstation, vielleicht sieht man das hier.
Ich habe da irgendwie so einen alten, so einen
alten Stream, wo das im Titel vorkam.
Ordnung pur.
Bei mir am Start. Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ich blick bei meinem eigenen Video
nicht durch. Zumindest
das Gute an dieser Lötstation ist,
dass die, der Lötkolben
hat, ist relativ
klein und hat
einen sehr elastischen
Schlauchkabel
Ja, also du kannst das, du kannst
das in die Hand nehmen und kannst das in allen Winkeln
und so bewegen. Also ich kann das Ding empfehlen.
Damit macht das wirklich Spaß
Sachen zu löten.
Die 5 Euro abisolierte
Zange, ich glaube nicht, dass ich ne, ach die
diese Yokari Zange, ja, das ist der
abisolierte Champ, ja, den
haben viele.
Die kostet aber mehr als 5 Euro, aber das ist eine der
günstigeren, das stimmt.
Macht Lötzinn auch einen Unterschied?
Keine Ahnung, da habe ich immer
eine Billigrolle bisher gehabt und die hat gut funktioniert.
Also ich würde dir für den
Heimgebrauch auf jeden Fall Lötzinn
empfehlen mit
ner ordentlichen Mischung.
Also nicht reines Zinn.
Wenn du jetzt irgendwas professionell machst,
keine Ahnung, ich bin mir da nicht sicher, aber ich glaube
so, professionelle
Anwender dürfen wirklich nur noch Lötzinn
ohne Blei verwenden.
Aber im Heimbereich darf
man noch diese klassischen Lötzinn
Mischung mit Blei verwenden und Flussmittel.
Und damit ist es im
Heimbereich viel einfacher zu löten
als mit reinem Lötzinn.
Wo hast du das Custom-PCB
her von PCBWay?
China-Chinesenkram.
Ja, aber diesmal ordentlich
im Vorfeld und nicht irgendwie zwei Tage.
Ich bin bei Vodafone.
Zed, Zedj.
Okay, so, jetzt müssen wir langsam anfangen.
Stunde am Start, nur rumgeschwätzt.
Lumiko, danke schön
für den Sub. Gar nicht.
Gehe ich stark von aus.
Warum nicht, dass das in nächster Zeit
passieren wird? Okay.
Das macht richtig Bock. Nein, Hilfe
kann ich mir nicht geben.
Es gibt so ein paar Sachen,
kann ich nichts mit anfangen.
Ich habe früher ab und zu mal gelesen, aber
mittlerweile nervt mich
die Art und Weise, wie die Sachen geschrieben sind.
Mir auch. Mir macht es auch Spaß.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was er mittlerweile so treibt.
Ich lese da gar nichts mehr.
So, jetzt aber.
Eigentlich wollte ich mir mit euch
im Biome
JS oder... Ich weiß nicht genau,
wie man es ausspricht.
Ich erkenne das Logo auch ehrlich
gesagt nicht, was das sein soll.
Was ist das Logo,
Leute? Was sieht man da?
Versucht das gerade zu erkennen.
Ich bin eh schlecht so im Logos erkennen.
Was ist das? Ist das ein Archlinux Logo?
Plus Fake Archlinux Logo?
Was soll das sein?
Erkennt das jemand?
Also, es gibt ja genug Logos,
wenn man die sich eine Weile anguckt, dann erkennt man es.
Ein Dreieck mit Kreis.
Und was hat das mit Biom
zu tun? Oder Biom?
Man weiß es nicht, oder?
Das ist ein Facepalmendes Archlinux Logo.
Ich habe auch gedacht,
das sieht ein bisschen aus wie das Flex Emoji,
gell? Das habe ich mir auch gerade gedacht,
hier. Wie so ein Flex.
Ja, ich erkenne es nicht.
Ist auch wurscht.
Was das ist, das ist egal.
Es ist written in Rust.
Sollte deine Frage schon beantworten, oder?
Egal was es ist,
aber solange es written in Rust ist,
muss es POC sein.
An String erinnern, das ist eine gute Idee.
Das Logo ist so blazingly fast,
dass man es gar nicht erkennen kann, ja.
Also,
Biom ist ein fast formatter
for JavaScript.
Das ist so ein bisschen was wie Prettier.
Ja, es erfüllt 97%
compatibility
mit, das ist so ein Wort, das ich nicht aussprechen kann,
mit Prettier. Aber,
dadurch, dass es written in Rust ist,
ist es blazingly
fast, Leute.
Und, warum ich das ausprobieren will,
also was mir ja persönlich gefällt ist,
dass es anscheinend
mit ziemlich guten Def...
also, was ich gelesen habe, ja.
Mit guten Default Settings kommt,
man gar nicht viel konfigurieren muss, und
das meiste, was man so braucht,
out of the box, ohne Custom Plugins
mit dabei ist.
Zum Beispiel werden, wird
Svelte unterstützt,
und es wird das Sortieren
von Tailwind-Klassen unterstützt und sowas.
Das wollen
die schon mal ausprobieren.
Deswegen machen wir das einfach.
Mal gucken, ob das taugt.
Ich verwende normalerweise auch noch nicht mal
Prettier. Ich benutze den
Standard in Visual Studio Code integrierten
Codeformatter, aber
der suckt in manchen Fällen
richtig hart.
Und ich dachte mir,
probieren wir doch einfach mal was
Neues aus. Und wenn es dann auch noch
blazingly fast written in Rust ist,
warum nicht? Ich würde sagen,
wir legen
mal ein
irgendein neues Testprojekt an.
mkdir
biome-test
Legen wir eine neue Svelte-Anwendung an.
Ich mache mal ein Update.
Da stehe ich, da stehe ich immer
da stehe
ich immer auf dem
Schlauch, Leute.
Tut das hier jetzt
Svelte updaten
und das neueste Create-Skript
ausführen? Oder nimmt das
das Lateste, was ich installiert habe?
Also muss ich vorher ein NPM
Update machen? Oder
geht das auch so? Ich
check das JavaScript-Ökosystem nicht.
Nimmt das Neueste in der
Registry, also 6, okay
Proceed, yes.
Ja, hier. Achso, Moment.
Wartet mal. Ich glaube, ich hätte gar
keinen Punkt angeben müssen.
Hit Enter Current Directory.
SkeletonKit
Ja, also quasi ohne
irgendwas großartiges dabei. Kein TypeScript
erst einmal. Wir tryen
Svelte 5, na wenn schon, wenn schon, denn schon.
Ja, okay.
NPM installen.
Wenn das durch ist, nachdem wir
das halbe Internet runtergeladen haben,
machen wir Visual Studio Code auf und gucken uns
das Ganze mal an. Also mit
mit biome dann.
Noch gibt es nichts zu sehen,
weil noch ist das einfach nur stinknormale
Default SvelteKit App.
Ich werde, ich werde in dieser App auch
nichts machen, außer
außer, und das müssen wir machen,
weil ansonsten werde ich blind.
Ähm,
außer, wo
machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Page?
Diff? Was?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wait a minute, wait a minute.
Ich muss umschalten auf
ähm
Profile Web.
Okay.
Nice.
Äh, Diff. Wir machen nämlich
die Hintergrundfarbe ein bisschen anders.
Wie keine Ahnung, Style,
Background, Color,
ja, keine Ahnung,
Grey oder so.
Äh, muss ich das
muss ich das
hier machen?
Ah, yes. Okay.
Es sieht, es sieht scheiße aus, aber da geht's
nicht drum.
Alter.
Recon Svelte for VS Code.
Hab ich doch installiert.
Warum sollt, was
denkt der denn? Hab ich doch installiert.
Ach so. Restart. Okay.
Nur 52 Packages.
Ja, das ist für Frontend Projekte in der
Tat wenig. Ja, das stimmt.
Starten das mal
hier. So.
52 Packages ist nix.
Im JavaScript
Umfeld. Im JavaScript Umfeld
da hast du Packages für
äh, is odd, is even. Ich hab ein
Tool Request letztens gesehen.
Da musste ich auch extrem kecken.
Und zwar, remove
is number.
Da gab, ich weiß nicht wo ich das gelesen
hab. Daumen auf Reddit
oder so. Da hat einer
ernsthaft ein Package am Start,
was sich is number nennt.
Sechs Jahre zuletzt aktualisiert
wurde. Und der einzige Inhalt
von diesem Package ist das hier.
Und irgendjemand
hat
dieses Package
entfernt als Dependency.
Und, also
sein Package wurde selbst oft
verwendet. Und er hat durch das Entfernen
dieser Dependency
600 Gigabyte Traffic
eingespart.
Ich glaube, irgendwo auf Reddit hab ich
das gelesen. Ich glaube nicht, dass
ich das noch finde. Ah, hier
doch.
This PR replaces is number Package
with one line of... Okay,
sorry, 600 Gigabyte, 440
Gigabyte weekly traffic.
Ja, also das muss anscheinend selbst ein
relativ beliebtes Package sein.
So.
This tiny change saves
440 Gigabyte weekly traffic.
Und es hat sich
geändert. Und es hat sich
geändert. Er hat is number
rausgeschmissen und hat es ersetzt durch
das gleiche.
Also, das Javascript
Ökosystem ist einfach...
Man kann nicht sagen im Arsch,
weil Javascript hat eines der besten
Ökosysteme, die es gibt. Aber
schon speziell
trifft es, glaube ich, ganz gut. Moin
Zetire.
Es ist speziell, das Javascript Ökosystem.
Wirklich sehr, sehr speziell.
So. Da machen
wir jetzt einfach hier Omega Lull
als Überschrift. Das muss reichen.
So. Und das Allerwichtigste,
wir brauchen Pond.
Ich kann das überhaupt nicht richtig ohne
Arial. Hier, bam.
Okay. Beste. Ich würde sagen, das ist
die Web-Anwendung des Jahres.
Jetzt schauen wir mal,
wie das hier mit Biom funktioniert.
So.
Also, was man Biom verwenden kann,
ist... Also, wenn ich hier zum Beispiel
jetzt so Dinger Kacke einrücke, ja?
Und drücke STRG S,
dann... Ups.
Save. Dann wird das Auto
formatiert und saved.
Manchmal ist der Auto-Format da aber
ein bisschen... ein bisschen wild.
Ja? Zum Beispiel, wo
er mal ganz schnell
durcheinander kommt, ist,
wenn man mehrere Tailwind-Klassen
hier drin stehen hat,
dann macht es teilweise ganz, ganz
wirres Zeug.
Der Formatter. Und manchmal,
und das macht mich auch immer verrückt,
manchmal
macht er die Zeilenumbrüche
der Formatter so, dass es irgendwie
so schließt und sowas.
Ganz, ganz wirr.
Deswegen, so richtig der
weiß als letzter Schluss, ist dieser in Visual Studio Code
eingebauter Formatter nicht.
Ja, für so einfache Dinger funktioniert es wunderbar.
Und manchmal hört er komplett
auf. Gibt er komplett,
gibt er komplett den Geist auf, ja? Also zum Beispiel
hatte ich hier schon, hatte ich hier schon Probleme,
wenn ich irgendwie neue, neue
Svelte 5 Syntax hier
teilweise verwendet habe.
Und dann ging, ging das, ups, ja...
Weiß ich aus dem Kopf gar nicht, wie das
funktioniert, was? I5 oder so?
Wie ging das jetzt?
So.
Jetzt sagen kann es hier Lock, wenn sich
I, wenn, wenn I sich ändert, ja?
Und da habe ich beispielsweise das Problem gehabt,
mit, mit der passenden Svelte 5
Syntax ging es, kam das Plugin nicht klar
und ist abgekackt. Aber es kann sein, dass es besser
funktioniert. So.
Und Biome hat einen eingebauten
Prettier oder so einen Formatter,
der wohl relativ gute
Default Settings hat, Blazingly
Fast ist, weil er written in Rust ist
und, und das ist das, was ich, was ich
sehr cool finde, viele Sachen
out of the box mitbringt. Denn, wenn man jetzt
zum Beispiel Tailwind verwendet, das können wir jetzt hier
machen. Tailwind.
Ja, irgendwie so, zack.
Yes.
Ich hoffe, das stimmt, was ich jetzt hier mache.
Es ändert sich nämlich auch laufend, wie das funktioniert.
Aha, okay, ist mal wieder
outdated. Nice.
Fuck's, Alter. Kann da nicht mal eine Sache
drei Monate aktuell bleiben?
JavaScript, by the way.
Okay, wir verwenden schon das, das Richtige.
Wir haben schon das Richtige verwendet.
Was?
Fuck, das ist das Falsche gewesen, was ich verwendet habe.
Warum ist das falsch?
Das ist doch original, das, was ich
hier steht, oder? Ich habe das
doch original von hier...
Es wird ja immer besser. Wie?
Ich habe das von hier kopiert und jetzt ist das
unknown option? Und was
habe ich vorhin ausgeführt? Das. Okay.
Da gab es diese Option noch.
Alter, wollt ihr mich eigentlich
komplett verarschen?
Frontend-Stelzer. Äh.
Wahnsinn. Okay.
Hat es jetzt...
Okay, ich habe legit
keinen Plan. Ich lasse es jetzt einfach
weg, okay? Einfach...
Ich lasse es weg.
Moment...
Jetzt darf ich es sagen, yes?
Okay, ist egal.
Das passt schon.
So. Und nun,
wenn wir Glück haben, können wir
Tailwind Classes verwenden. Ich hoffe, das hat jetzt
alles funktioniert. Muss das so?
Ich hoffe mal.
Wisst ihr was? Ich lösche
das nochmal.
Bin nicht sicher, ob das so
funktioniert, wie das sein muss.
Yes.
Okay.
Nee, das muss nämlich nicht so sein. Da war
jetzt zu viel drin.
Okay, so. Jetzt haben wir Tailwind am Start.
Ich hoffe, das
stimmt jetzt alles.
Standardmäßig. Typografie und so.
Alles gut. So, und jetzt kann ich
hier sowas machen, wie Class.
Gleich. Ah, jetzt hat
das... Blue.
Nee, muss man hier...
Color. Nee, wie geht
das nochmal? Nee, Text.
Text. Genau. Text.
Blue 800. So.
Okay.
Jetzt kann sein, dass ich das nochmal neu starten muss.
Ah, ja.
Okay. Wunderbar.
Excellent.
Text XXXL
5xXL.
Bam.
Indigo 900.
Das war massive.
Designed. Krassestes
Design, Web Design
ever. So.
Und jetzt probieren wir das Ganze mal mit Biom aus,
weil Biom kann angeblich Weltfiles
formatieren und es kann Tailwind
Klassen sortieren. Das probieren
wir doch gleich mal aus. Wir machen übrigens mal hier diesen
Background Style da weg. Achtung,
Leute, Flashbang.
Wir machen jetzt hier irgendwie BG.
Style
machen wir hier weg.
Class gleich BG.
Spray
700.
700. Können wir jetzt noch sagen, irgendwie
volle Breite und volle
Höhe? Geht das irgendwie?
Nee, das geht nicht.
Wie geht das? View
Height oder sowas? Ah, ja.
Ja, ich will das nicht mit Prettier machen.
Das ist es doch.
So.
Kacke.
Excellent.
Text XL
5xXL.
Optische
Augenweide hier.
So. Und dann probieren wir das nochmal aus. So. Wie
funzt das jetzt?
Das ist ja unser Demo-Projekt. Biom.
Wie installiert man das?
Biom.js.
Lasst uns mal gucken.
One Toolchain for your Webproject.
Das ist schön.
NPM.
What?
NPM
I-D--save
exact. Okay.
I ist Install, minus D ist
Def Dependencies. Save exact.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
NPM hat eh 800 verschiedene
Options, wo keiner weiß, was die so genau machen.
Try to format. Okay, wir machen mal kurz den git commit.
Weil nicht, dass ich das jetzt
irgendwie zerschieße und das dann nochmal anlegen muss.
Git
git add
minus git commit
Ja. Puh puh. Perfekt.
Okay.
Dann machen wir das mal. Jetzt erleben wir das jetzt. Gucken, was
passiert. Also.
Wir formatieren mal da irgendwie Mist. Okay?
Oder gucken, ob was am Ende... Moment. Die...
Moment, Moment. Angeblich, da gibt's ja auch ein Visual Studio Code
Plugin. Biome.
Alter, was geht mit der Musik ab?
Okay, wir installieren einfach das Visual Studio
Code Addon. Viel, viel nicer.
Okay, mein Formatter
ist kaputt. Und Biome
greift irgendwie...
Macht das Weltplugin kaputt?
Muss ich einfach mal reloaden vielleicht? Reload?
Ah, schon. Ne.
Achso, ich soll das Const machen, ha?
Aber das Formatieren
funktioniert schon nochmal net.
Format. Format document.
There are multiple
Formatters for... Should be configured
as a default configure. Okay.
Biome. Okay, hat funktioniert.
Es hat...
Es hat formatiert. Nice.
Äh, aber...
Mein HTML wird nicht formatiert.
Das ist... Das ist doof.
Das bringt schon mal nix. Was ist, wenn ich
auf der Kommandozeile ausführe?
Ist source überhaupt richtig? Ich glaub schon.
Source. Ja.
Lassen wir's mal... Lassen wir's mal einfach
auf meinem Projekt los. Gutes. Bam.
Format your three files
in 705 microseconds.
Wieso kein
COBOL?
Wir machen's in COBOL, wenn
du mir nen IBM Host vorbeischickst.
So, was hat sich jetzt geändert?
git diff
Also, das Ding hat
meine Package.json formatet.
Das hättest du nicht unbedingt machen müssen.
Und es hat meine...
Leute, das ist aber ziemlich...
unsinnig,
wenn es kein HTML
formatieren kann. Da müssen wir mal
reingucken, was die da schreiben, weil ich hab eigentlich
gelesen, dass... dass Svelte
angeblich supported ist.
Es sagt aber, wenn das
nicht richtig funktioniert.
Docs...
Svelte...
Language support.
Nee, der Vorteil davon ist ja angeblich,
dass du keine Config unbedingt brauchst.
Dass die... Das schreiben die auch.
Dass die Default Settings
durchdacht sind, dass es
erstmal einfach nur funktioniert.
Soll eines der Vorteile davon sein.
So, Svelte wird supportet, allerdings
nicht alles.
Und zwar...
Wenn formatting
will start from the
beginning...
HTML not supported. Wo steht das?
Ich seh das net.
In der Tabelle? Ach, stimmt!
Moment, das Ding kann
kein HTML formatieren?
Ja, was ist denn das?
Wollt ihr mich veräppeln?
Moment, das...
What? Wie jetzt?
Es gibt Formatter, die kein HTML
formatieren können?
Ich mein, das wär jetzt nicht weiter schlimm,
wenn
Visual Studio Code schlau genug wär
und diesen Part
hier mit dem normalen HTML Formatter
formatiert, aber
macht das ja anscheinend nicht.
Ja, das ist ziemlich...
Was ist denn das für ein Kack?
Das kann doch net sein.
Mach mal PR, ist ja Rust. Easy!
Wir bauen kurz HTML ein.
Das muss doch irgendwie anders funktionieren.
Das kann man doch bestimmt.
Next will be HTML.
Ok, next vor nem Jahr.
Ich war's ja net.
Ok, jetzt ist natürlich die Frage,
kann man diesem Visual Studio Plugin,
diesem Svelte Plugin...
Settings... Ne, äh...
UI...
Wie heißt dieses Ding?
User?
References...
Was da?
Extension?
Pio, was haben wir hier zum umstellen?
Copilot?
Ne, ne, ne.
So, und hier
Svelte Extensions?
Language?
Also...
Ich seh jetzt da nix von Formatting.
Sieht man da irgendwas von Formatting?
Hier! Format!
Ne, das ist das,
was es defaultmäßig machen soll.
Also,
es ist kein Visual Studio Code
Problem
per se, weil über
Kommandozeile funktioniert das auch nicht.
Vielleicht kann man das Svelte Plugin in Visual Studio Code
aber überreden,
das anders zu formatieren.
Oder auch net? Hm...
Ne, aber...
Wo hab ich denn das eben umgestellt?
Bei JavaScript, oder?
Formatter...
Formatting...
Wo konnte man eben den Formatter umstellen?
Wo war denn das?
Ich hab doch eben den Formatter irgendwo umgestellt.
Aber hier ist schon mal net.
Unübersichtlicher Shit
teilweise, ey.
VSCode, Change,
JavaScript, Formatter... Irgendwo hab ich den doch umgestellt.
Es...
Ah ja, das ist auch ne gute Idee.
Nen Plugin, um das andere nochmal hinterherlaufen zu lassen.
Boah, ich weiß net.
Ja, das macht ja anscheinend das Svelte Plugin.
Aber das haut wohl die ganze
Seite an den Default Formatter.
Das ist halt bissl...
Ok, Leute, ich bin zu blöd zu finden.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wo der
Formatter ist, zum Einstellen.
Das ist auch unübersichtlich.
Erst fuck alles wieder.
Ja. Format Document.
Ja, das hatte ich ja gerade, aber...
Hier kann man's... Config Default Formatter.
Ja.
Svelte Visual Studio Code.
Ja, jetzt checkt's das.
Ist doch blöd.
Ja, aber warum... Das muss doch auch irgendwo in den Settings hier drinnen stehen.
Ich weiß, dass es ne Config Datei gibt.
Aber da steht doch auch irgendwo in den Settings.
Ich find das so krass unübersichtlich.
Ich hätte eigentlich gerne das irgendwo
bei Text Editor oder...
Zumindest wenn man nach Formatter sucht.
Ja, wir können auch irgendwie die Settings öffnen.
Äh...
User Settings, JSON.
Immer ich alles hier für'n Shit
drin hab. Hier.
Svelte Editor Default Formatter.
Ok. Aber wenn ich hier nach
Formatter such...
Ist ein None.
Da muss das wahrscheinlich echt...
Woher weiß der denn, was man hier eigentlich hat?
Ja, das ist schon...
Das ist schon doof, oder?
Gibt's denn hier sonst noch?
Editor Format...
Aber nacheinander? Wie soll das funktionieren?
Da brauchst du irgendein Plugin, um es
nacheinander laufen zu... Das ist doch alles
Kacke. Das kannst du doch schon wieder
alles komplett vergessen.
Wenn so Basic Dinger wie
Ich will HTML Format...
Aber jetzt mal...
Wenn das Ding kein HTML
formatieren kann, wie
kann es denn Tailwind-Klassen
formatieren? Das kann nämlich
angeblich Tailwind-Klassen formatieren.
Das heißt, das kann...
Tags
in Klassen formatieren, aber
nicht das HTML drumherum?
Leon, das ist normal.
Web-Entwicklung ist
PaintChamp. Das muss PaintChamp sein.
Also anscheinend
kann das Klassen formatieren
in HTML, aber nicht HTML
selbst. Sehr
merkwürdig.
Und wie würde man das denn jetzt überhaupt
formatieren?
Und wie konfiguriert man
das Ding?
Examples. Invalid.
Ja, aber wie... Code-related
Options.
Configuration. Gibt's da vielleicht
auch mal ne Example-Configuration?
Ey, nee.
Das ist doch für'n Arsch.
Also wenn das... Mir bringt's ja auch nix, wenn
das Tailwind-Klassen sorten kann, solange es HTML
nicht sortieren kann.
Das ist doch Schrott.
Sie sind hier wild am diskutieren
über HTML.
Support.
Ich glaube, das funktioniert schlicht und ergreifend
aktuell noch nicht.
Okay, dann hat sich der Stream erledigt.
Ist nicht usable für mich aktuell.
Nice.
Okay. rm-rf.
Weg damit.
Keck weh, Alter.
Hat sich ja gelohnt, das auszuprobieren.
Okay, Chat, was wollen wir
jetzt?
Ich dachte
eigentlich, dass es was taugt, ehrlich gesagt.
Übrigens, Leon.
Wenn du es nicht übertreiben willst,
ich geh mal davon aus,
du willst prinzipiell nur Frontend
machen. Du brauchst keinerlei
Backend oder sonstige Geschichten.
Wenn du einfach
nur ne Webseite machen willst,
statischer Content,
dann musst du dich, ehrlich gesagt,
gar nicht so sehr damit auseinandersetzen.
Es tut's,
wenn du
ne HTML-Seite nimmst
und
bisschen HTML und CSS machst.
Wenn du es ein bisschen einfacher haben willst,
ich persönlich mag Svelte
als Frontend-Framework.
Das kannst du auch als
statische Web-Anwendung
generieren lassen
und musst es dann einfach nur auf den Web-Server hauen
und dann geht's. Das ist sinnvoll,
wenn du bisschen JavaScript drinnen machen willst
und dich nicht mit
Vanilla JavaScript
rumärgern willst
oder gar mit jQuery oder sowas.
Das finde ich ganz nice.
Ansonsten, wenn es einfach nur ne
Seite sein soll. Hallo, ich bin Leon
und hab die und die drei Projekte gemacht.
Mach ne statische
HTML-Seite und fertig.
Vielleicht Tailwind drinnen,
wenn man ein bisschen netter CSS
designen möchte, aber ansonsten
braucht man doch nix großartiges.
Web ist prinzipiell
immer Paintschamp.
Nee, das machen wir heute nicht.
Also wir werden ja heute weder
Rust programmieren noch nix zu erst machen.
Ja, das ging jetzt tatsächlich ein bisschen schneller,
als mir das lieb ist,
ehrlich gesagt.
Was gibt's denn
noch für aktuelle...
Ich weiß es! Wobei, das wollte ich mir
morgen früh mit euch angucken.
Das gibt ja das Stack Overflow
Survey 2024
wieder. Aber das gucken wir uns morgen
früh an. Nicht jetzt.
Was, im Mai?
Ah ja, die Auswertung
gab's jetzt.
Ah ja, und wenn man...
Ich wollte grad was ähnliches sagen.
Wenn man einfach nur ein bisschen Content
haben will, dann würde ne Markdown-Seite
auch reichen.
Kannst du uns über deine Geschenke
berichten? Naja,
mit 40 gibt's da nicht mehr so viel
Spannendes.
Ich versteh auch, dass es schwierig ist,
was zum Geburtstag zu schenken ist,
wenn man sich die Sachen einfach
kauft, wenn er sie braucht.
Schwierig ist, was zum Geburtstag zu schenken.
Lass mal überlegen, was ist das Beste,
was ich zum Geburtstag gekriegt hab?
Weit ja glücklicherweise keiner zu.
Ähm...
Doch, ich weiß, was das Beste ist.
Ich weiß, was das Beste zum Geburtstag
war. Also, das ist
keine Sache,
die einem direkt geschenkt wird. Meine Mutter hat mir
was gebacken.
Und
den hab ich,
das war so
semi-groß,
großer Kuchen, ja.
Und den hab ich in
eineinhalb Tagen komplett gefressen.
Und Nudeln
mit Lachs!
Nudeln mit Lachs hab ich heute gegessen, tatsächlich!
Hi Wubblos,
denkst du, aktuell
bekomme ich als
Berufseinsteiger gut einen Job, oder wird das
in 1-2 Jahren besser?
Ich kann dazu nicht viel
sagen.
Ich kenne mich da
nicht aus, was da aktuell
abgeht. Also,
auf Reddit
liest es sich aktuell so, als
ist es nicht ganz so toll, gerade als
Einsteiger. Schreibt ja auch der Chat
gerade. Aber insgesamt
suchen die ja immer noch händeringend
nach Leuten. Aber auf Reddit
sind, ich wollt grad sagen, auf Reddit sind halt auch
sehr viele merkwürdige Leute.
Das sind auch die, die permanent
schreiben,
sobald irgendwas ist,
kündigen
und dem Chef auf den Tisch
scheißen und abhauen.
Reddit ist da so ein bisschen
fragwürdig, ja.
Egal wo du guckst, im Finanzen
Subreddit, im Azubi Subreddit,
im, äh,
wie heißt das andere?
Arbeitsleben Subreddit.
Alles merkwürdige Leute.
Ansonsten wäre halt auch
tatsächlich die Frage, als was
Einsteiger, ja.
Na gut, in Berlin brauchst du das wahrscheinlich auch,
dass du dir die Wohnung überhaupt leisten kannst.
In Berlin soll es ja angeblich
relativ teuer sein. Ich hab keine,
ich hab selbst keine Erfahrung mit Berlin,
was da Wohnen
und Wohnungen und so angeht.
Ich war in meinem Leben, glaube
ich, also bewusst
jetzt, woran ich mich erinnern kann, einmal in Berlin
und das ist eine der Städte gewesen, wo ich
nicht wieder hin will. Mir hat
Berlin überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Es hat mich am
Hauptbahnhof tatsächlich ein bisschen an Frankfurt
sogar erinnert.
Ich hab die kleine Sehenswürdigkeits-
Tour gemacht, also
ich hab mir quasi das Brandenburger
Tor und den Reichstag und sowas
und was da sonst so drumherum steht,
irgendwelche Denkmäler für
den Zweiten Weltkrieg und whatever noch alles,
bin ich dran vorbeigelaufen, hab's mir
angeguckt, das Gute in Berlin ist in dem Fall tatsächlich,
die ganzen Sehenswürdigkeiten sind
irgendwie alle so im Umkreis.
Du fährst vorn fünf Kilometer,
läufst einmal im Kreis, hast alles gesehen
und dann gehst du zum Hauptbahnhof und fährst heim
und tschüss.
Also Berlin hat mir nicht gefallen.
Berlin war dreckig,
zumindest da, wo ich langgelaufen bin
und hat sich
auf den ersten Blick, was das angeht,
nicht großartig von Frankfurt
unterschieden. Ja, okay,
Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel
ist vielleicht noch ein
Ticken ätzender und schlimmer,
aber das erste, was ich in Berlin hatte, ist
ich hab
die Tür auf, also erstens hab ich mich verlaufen
im Hauptbahnhof, weil ich nicht wusste,
welcher der richtige Ausgang ist, weil beides
irgendwie gleich aussah. Aber dann hab ich's
gefunden, ich hab die Tür aufgemacht
und das erste, was ich hatte, ich mach
die Tür auf und es steht instant
ein Penner vor mir und hustet mir ins Gesicht.
Da dachte ich mir so, ist ja wieder
heim. Kein
Unterschied. Warum musste ich da erst nach Berlin
fahren? Ja, aber dann
war ich damals beim Battlefield
äh
eins
Event
und das Event war auch
nicht gut. Also ich fand's
kacke in Berlin und der Grund, warum ich
hingefahren bin, war auch kacke
und deswegen
hab ich keine allzu guten positiven Erinnerungen
an Berlin.
Das letzte Mal in Dresden war's, das ist tatsächlich
auch schon ein paar Jahre her.
Kann ich dir nicht mehr sagen.
Ist aber schon ein bisschen her.
Ich hab aktuell keinen Grund nach
Dresden zu fahren. Ja,
ich weiß nicht genau, was der Fabian treibt
und der Carsten,
was ist denn nun mit Carsten los? Der Carsten hat jetzt irgendwie
zwei Kinder und
macht da halt
Papa-Stelz, ja.
Also gibt keinen,
der Zeit hätte, der Bock hätte irgendwie da,
den ich da besuchen könnte.
Ansonsten fand ich Dresden nice. Also mir
persönlich hat Dresden gefallen.
Auch
also
wird ja immer gesagt, so auch im Osten ist alles so
so wenig Geld und sonst was, ohne Scheiß.
Dresden war DEUTLICH
ruhiger und ordentlicher
und sauberer als Frankfurt.
In Dresden
konntest du ohne Probleme über irgendeinen Platz
laufen und
dich haben keine
komischen Leute angebettelt
oder
oder du bist in irgendeinen Dreck getreten
oder irgendwelche Leute
lagen dir im Weg oder so.
Das war echt ganz,
es war auch vor allem deutlich leiser.
Ja, okay,
das stimmt.
Das stimmt voll, da hast du Recht.
Wir waren, wir waren
abends in irgendeinem Kaufhaus
oder so, da war so ein Klamottenladen.
Da stand ein Schwarzer davor.
Der hat etwas
nervös gewirkt in Dresden, wahrscheinlich zu Recht.
Ja, das stimmt wahrscheinlich als
weißerste Seinfacher, aber insgesamt
war das wirklich sehr angenehm in Dresden.
Und eine Sache,
woran ich mich tatsächlich noch erinnern kann,
das erste Mal, als ich in Dresden war,
und das ist schon ganz lange her, da habe ich tatsächlich
auch den Fabian besucht damals,
das war aber bestimmt noch
keine Ahnung, 2000,
keine Ahnung,
2003 oder so.
Oder 2004 oder so.
Das ist ewig her
gewesen, 20 Jahre
oder so. Ja, muss ich,
es ist echt hart, Leute.
Vor 20 Jahren war ich 20, kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen,
oder?
Krass.
Naja.
Richtig Boomer ab.
Ich bin jetzt übrigens seit ein paar Tagen
offiziell Hyperboomer.
Ich bin jetzt 40 geworden, letztens.
Ja.
Schon ganz schön lang.
Her, 1984.
Zumindest
das erste Mal, als ich in Dresden war,
nicht 1984,
1984 nach Dresden war noch ein bisschen problematischer.
Also 2003
oder 2004 rum, da weiß ich noch,
bin ich da Eis essen gegangen mit dem Fabian
und da hat die Kugel Eis,
das ist so die typische Story aus dem Osten,
ja, da hat die Kugel Eis
die Hälfte gekostet, von hier.
Ich vermute
mal, dass es
20 Cent
oder 30 Cent oder irgendwas
gewesen sind oder so.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, also es hat,
es hat, ich weiß,
also,
das Bällchen hat vor 2000
eine Marke gekostet und bis hin danach,
es hat eine Weile gedauert,
bis wir bei einem Euro waren. Das heißt, wir waren dann auch nicht
bei einem Euro. Also sagen wir mal so,
wenn wir bei einem Euro waren, dann waren wir im Osten
bei 50 Cent. Hat es wahrscheinlich 50 Cent
gekostet, ja.
Und das fand ich extrem nice und ich habe ganz
viel Eis gefressen in Dresden, weil es so billig war.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Ansonsten hat es mir, hat mir Dresden
echt ganz gut gefallen.
Das war relativ sauber,
recht ruhig,
mag vielleicht auch an dem Tag
und der Zeit gewesen sein.
Aber fand ich, fand ich nice, ja.
Wir waren bei so einem
All-You-Can-Eat-China-Chinesen-Laden,
da. So, so einen
Running-Sushi-Laden. Ey, und der Fabian und ich,
Leute, wir haben den Laden leer gefressen, ne.
Wir haben da irgendwie zwei Stunden drinnen gehockt,
also wir haben die maximale Zeit, die mir sitzen durfte,
ausgenutzt und wir haben, glaube ich, keine
Ahnung, jeder 35 Schüssel
gefuttert oder so.
Und am Ende hat es, keine Ahnung, was es am Ende
gekostet hat, irgendwie
7,50 Euro oder sowas. Das war
mega billig. Ja, richtig,
richtig nice.
Mittlerweile ist es bestimmt auch nicht mehr so
billig, aber ich vermute wahrscheinlich,
also ich meine, könnt ihr mal sagen, ihr seht ja vielleicht ein paar Leute
jetzt aus Dresden und Umgebung oder aus dem Osten da,
ich vermute mal, dass es aber immer noch
im Verhältnis
billiger ist als hier.
Also in Frankfurt kannst du ohne Probleme so
1,70
bezahlen.
1,80,
2 Euro vielleicht sogar für, für eine
Eiskugel. Bei mir im Ort kostet
die Eiskugel, je nachdem wo ich hingehe,
1,50, 1,50 so.
Wie, wie viel kostet die Kugel Eis
im Osten gerade?
Meinst du, die haben den Laden leergefressen? Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass
der pleite ist, nur durch uns.
Nee, der ist definitiv nicht pleite, nur
durch uns, weil, als ich ein paar Jahre
später wieder da war,
gab es den Laden noch, da waren wir wieder da.
Also alles gut. Echt?
Eis kostet, okay, Moment mal, Moment mal.
Dresden
Kugel Eis Preis.
Das muss ich jetzt nachgucken.
Soviel kostet eine,
hier gibt es eine Kugel Eis für 90 Cent.
Die Kugel Speiseeis
für 1,37 Euro.
Okay, mal ernsthaft. Welche Eisdiele
macht 1,37 Euro
für eine Eiskugel? Die sind ja nur mit
Kleingeld beschäftigt.
Muss den Streamtitel irgendwie ändern.
Ich weiß nicht, auf was ändere ich den Streamtitel?
Keg Wait
Keg Waiting
Ach komm, ich lass den Streamtitel jetzt einfach,
ist mir doch egal. Ich bin eh bald off.
Biom hat nix
getaugt, by the way, falls irgendeiner
reinkommt und sich wundert.
Ja.
Keg Laberstells.
Das nennen wir jetzt.
Chat, waren die letzten Tage noch
irgendwas spannendes? Morgen früh bin ich ja wieder
am Start, da muss ich auch wieder
drei Stunden am Stück labern.
Darf ich nicht mal ein ganzes Pulver heute Abend schon verschießen?
Gab es irgendwas spannendes die letzten Tage?
Fällt euch
irgendwas ein?
Irgendwas spannendes so?
Die Olympia in Paris.
Ich hab tatsächlich
ein bisschen was geguckt.
Ich hab Cycling geguckt.
Mega nice.
Nebenbei zum Laufen lassen.
Fahrradfahren ist eines der wenigsten Sportarten,
die mich schon eine Weile interessieren.
Früher hab ich immer beim Opa geguckt.
Und ich hab tatsächlich
ein bisschen Leichtathletik geguckt.
Da ist mir wieder aufgefallen,
wie extrem krass
die Leute sind.
Ich renne fünf Kilometer
in ungefähr 25 Minuten.
Das ist gar nicht so langsam.
Das ist ganz okay.
Das ist auf jeden Fall weit schneller
als der Durchschnitt der Leute in Deutschland
das macht. Bin ich mir ziemlich sicher.
Und in der gleichen Zeit
rennen die dort fast
zehn Kilometer. Irgendwie
26,5 Minuten oder so. Zehn Kilometer.
Alter! Zehn Kilometer
in 26,5 Minuten.
Das ist so übertrieben krass.
Ich bin froh,
wenn ich zehn Kilometer in knapp
einer Stunde pack.
Das ist brutal.
Das kann man sich so als Normalsterblicher
gar nicht vorstellen.
Und mir war, bevor ich selbst
regelmäßig rennen gegangen bin,
oder auf Fahrrad fahren,
mir war schon immer klar,
dass die Leute schnell sind,
die bei Weltmeisterschaften und Olympia antreten.
Ich glaube, das ist jedem klar,
dass die schnell sind.
Aber ich konnte null einschätzen,
wie schnell die sind.
Genau vor 20 Jahren hätte ich das
sicherlich easy geschafft.
Man konnte überhaupt nicht einschätzen,
wie schnell die sind.
Und wenn ich mir angucke,
dass die
den Marathon,
dass die über 40 Kilometer
rennen
und das fast genau
doppelt so schnell
wie ich renne
den Kilometer.
Das war jetzt ein bisschen falsch ausgedrückt.
So schnell wie ich den Kilometer renne
bei fünf Kilometern,
rennen die 40 Kilometer
doppelt so schnell.
Ich brauche ungefähr
sagen wir mal,
ich brauche 5 Minuten
30 pro Kilometer.
Ich kann schneller,
aber wenn ich danach noch ein bisschen was machen will,
5 Minuten 30, sagen wir mal,
ist relativ angenehm.
5 Minuten 30 pro Kilometer renne ich.
5 Kilometer lang, alles gut.
Ja, dann sind das am Ende dann irgendwie so,
keine Ahnung, 26, 27 Minuten.
Und
die rennen einfach
2 Minuten 50
pro Kilometer
und das über 40 Kilometer.
Das ist, also
ey, das ist wirklich komplett
übertrieben.
Skaliert das mit den
heißt das dann auch,
dass man mit 10 doppelt so schnell ist
wie mit 20?
Ja ungefähr, also 2,50,
2,55 irgendwie so,
ist glaube ich so der Durchschnitts-Pace beim Marathon.
Das ist übertrieben krass.
Die rennen einfach doppelt so schnell wie ich
und ich renne nur 5 Kilometer.
Heißt logischerweise,
wenn du frisch auf die Welt gekommen bist,
bist du am schnellsten.
Du rennst am schnellsten,
wenn du noch nicht laufen kannst, das ist logisch.
Also das ist wirklich heftig,
wenn man das mal vergleicht. Ja.
Reddit ist natürlich,
äh nicht Reddit,
dazu sag ich jetzt nix,
weil dann artet das Thema wieder aus
und eigentlich geht es mir ziemlich am Arsch vorbei,
wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Twitter ist ja bei diesem Boxkampf da wieder komplett eskaliert.
Twitter,
X, nicht Reddit.
Da ist ja komplett Twitter wieder explodiert.
Alle wieder am ausflippen.
Die können keinen Arch installieren,
da bin ich mir relativ sicher.
Da bin ich mir relativ sicher,
dass die keinen Arch-Linux installieren können.
X formerly known as Twitter.
Korrekt.
Wie sagen die das eigentlich auf Deutsch?
X früher bekannt als Twitter?
Oder wie sagen die das immer?
Also wir können auf jeden Fall hier
in dem Stream schneller Arch installieren,
als die rennen.
Ich hab schneller Arch installiert, als die Kilometer gerannt sind.
Das krieg ich glaub ich hin.
Mit ein bisschen Übung.
Also Arch kann man wahrscheinlich mittlerweile
mit den passenden Befehlen
wahrscheinlich in 40 Sekunden oder so installieren.
Minimalinstallation
ohne zusätzliche Pakete und sowas.
Ja ich weiß, es gibt ein paar Arch-Linux Speedruns.
Ja, es ist echt so.
Wie gesagt,
früher wusste ich auch immer schon
im Hinterkopf, die müssen schnell sein,
sonst wären die nicht bei der Weltmeisterschaft,
sonst wären die nicht bei Olympia und so.
Aber seitdem ich selbst renne und Fahrrad fahre,
ist es einfach, seitdem kann ich einschätzen,
wie übertrieben schnell die sind.
Und sogar die Mädels,
1000 Kilometer, äh 1000 Kilometer,
Alter, 10, 10 Kilometer.
1000 Kilometer ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben.
10.000 Meter.
Die sind auch irgendwie, brauchen die nur
irgendwie 28 Minuten oder so.
Das ist super krass.
Die Anzahl der Faxgeräte
in Behörden könnte halbiert werden.
Wieso teilen sich dann zwei Behörden
ein Fax oder wie?
Das stimmt, die wirken nicht so schnell.
Weil man dann nicht weiß, wie schnell es eigentlich wirklich ist.
Vibrant Noob, danke schon für den Sub.
Pogu.
Mal wieder da mit dem üblichen Sonntag aufwachen
Streamstells-Programm.
Das mit Piyom hat ja heute nicht so richtig hingehauen,
wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Die sollten mal aufgrund von Crowdstrike
vielleicht nicht mal so viel
Windows-Schrott laufen lassen und mal was
anständiges.
So FreeBSD oder sowas.
Linux ist zu Mainstream mittlerweile.
DragonflyBSD.
Umso abgedrehter,
umso besser.
Bevor jetzt irgendeiner Tempel...
Ich wusste, dass einer TempelOS schreibt, Alter.
Ich wollte gerade noch sagen,
bevor jetzt einer TempelOS schreibt,
sag ich einfach noch TempelOS.
Weil ich wusste, dass gleich wieder irgendeiner mit um die Ecke kommt.
Das kannst du ja aber nicht
wirklich realistisch für irgendwas nennen.
HeikoOS schon eher.
Das ist ja der Nachfolger oder der
Open Source Klon von...
Oh, ich hab's vergessen.
Was ist Heiko nochmal?
BOS, oder?
BOS?
Ich glaub BOS.
Ich hab seit ein paar Wochen
hier neben mir am Schreibtisch so eine
Wasserflasche stehen.
Und das hilft mir wirklich enorm
genug zu trinken am Tag.
Das ist eine Wasserflasche,
die besteht aus so
komischem, geruchsneutralem
Plastik. Keine Ahnung, wie das heißt.
Das hat aber nicht diesen ekligen
Plastikgeschmack von vielen Plastikschmack...
von vielen Plastikflaschen.
Das ist sehr nice.
Was der einzige Nachteil ist...
Weiß nicht, was mit dem los ist,
aber da steht drauf,
dass da bis zu 32 Ounces
an Wasser reinpassen.
Und wer sich jetzt fragt, was sind 32 Ounces?
32 Ounces sind ungefähr
ein Liter.
Warum es in Ounces da drauf steht?
Keine Ahnung.
Ounces. Wer ist so hängen
geblieben
und misst den Inhalt seiner Trinkflasche
in Ounces?
Und drückt das auch noch da drauf.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Daku Pogs Subscription.
Jetzt geht es ja hier Schlag auf Schlag.
Und...
Viper Noob hat wieder
gegiftet. Habe ich gar nicht richtig vorgelesen, Freund.
Ähm...
EratraX
Pog Sub.
Sehr, sehr nice.
Ja, ich weiß, ich habe in letzter Zeit wenig gestreamt.
Das ist aber einfach eine Kombination aus
ich bin relativ viel am Basteln, wenn ich gerade sonst nichts zu tun habe.
Ich bin mittlerweile
jeden Tag rennen oder Fahrrad fahren.
Gerade Fahrrad fahren kann ich nicht einfach
nur eine Stunde Fahrrad fahren. Ich muss mindestens 2 Stunden
Fahrrad fahren, da ich das Gefühl habe, das hat sich gelohnt.
Ähm...
Ich bin recht unmotiviert, was Youtube
angeht gerade.
Und ich muss noch
ein paar andere Sachen machen.
Es hält sich gerade in Grenzen
meine Motivation, was
Youtube und Streaming angeht.
Aber das liegt nicht an euch.
Es ist nicht so, dass der Chat mich abgefuckt hätte oder so.
Also nicht mehr als sonst, ja.
Aber es ist glücklicherweise
nicht das ganze Jahr.
Und ich habe im Dezember wieder komplett
ganzen Monat Urlaub.
Was heißt, im Dezember ist wieder
Pogu Streaming
so angesagt.
Ja, ganzer Dezember Urlaub.
Mittlerweile, und das finde ich witzig, auf der neuen Arbeit
haben sie sich da auch schon dran gewöhnt.
Und im Urlaubsplan
für 2024 war
standardmäßig schon drin,
dass der Max einfach den ganzen Dezember
weg ist.
Leute, ich habe einen neuen FTP.
Habe ich euch das schon erzählt.
Wo ist denn hier? Performance Stats.
VO2 Max.
Genau.
Nicht keinen neuen FTP,
einen neuen VO2 Max.
Und zwar meine
meine ähm
Trainings Tracking App ist der Meinung,
dass ich jetzt
einen Running VO2 Max habe
von 44.
Das ist gut.
Und ich habe einen Cycling VO2 Max
von 46.
Und das ist, haltet euch vor,
exzellent für mein Alter.
Exzellent.
Und ich bin damit in den Top 30%
for your age and gender.
Also,
da sieht man mal, mit nur einem Jahr
sich ein bisschen anstrengen,
kriegt man schon was auf die Reihe.
Ziemlich genau in einem Jahr.
Basierte Fitness, ja.
Ich finde es witzig, dass
die App der Meinung ist,
ich kann angeblich besser Fahrrad fahren
oder habe mehr
Output beim Fahrradfahren als beim Rennen.
Dabei habe ich genau das Gegenteilige gefühlt.
Ich renne auch deutlich mehr, als dass ich Fahrrad fahre.
Ich finde Fahrradfahren
deutlich ähm
wie soll ich sagen
belastender
als Rennen, wenn man richtig Gas gibt.
Fahrradfahren ist super angenehm,
wenn man so mittel, mittel,
so semi, so semi hart
tritt, dann ist das viel angenehmer
als Rennen und auch
mit viel geringerem Puls ist alles super und toll.
Aber wenn man richtig hart reintritt,
finde ich, ist Fahrradfahren
viel belastender und heftiger
als Rennen.
Also gerade, weil dir übelst die Beine weh tun.
Beim Rennen ist es so, da tun dir nicht die Beine weh,
da kannst du halt einfach nicht mehr,
wenn du zu schnell rennst.
Du kannst nicht mehr die Puste aus.
Beim Fahrradfahren, bevor mir die Puste ausgeht,
kann ich nicht mehr weiter treten,
weil mir die Beine weh tun.
Was gab es heute zu essen?
Nudel mit Lachs.
Das gibt es morgen auch wieder.
Was für Specs zum Rennen, was meinst du?
Was für Specs?
Magst du mal eine Frage zu deiner Krankenversicherung?
Behältst du die Kondition von deiner, was?
Behältst du die Kondition?
Ja, mache ich.
Aber ich habe euch übrigens Mist erzählt.
Ab 1.8. oder so.
Privatversichert.
Ich bin tatsächlich nicht ab 1.8. privatversichert.
Sondern wahrscheinlich ab 1.9.
Weil man kann,
ich habe das irgendwie
nicht richtig gecheckt,
es ist irgendwie
zwei Monate
zum Monatsende
oder irgendwie so, wie man da wechseln kann.
Keine Ahnung.
Noch nicht, noch nicht.
Noch nicht ganz.
Ich habe
nichts an großartigen Vorerkrankungen.
Sonst wäre das
abartig teuer geworden.
Kommt man da jemals wieder raus?
Ja, wenn man das will,
schon. Aber es ist nicht einfach.
Also die einfachste Variante ist
wahrscheinlich Teilzeit
zu arbeiten, sodass man
unter die Grenze fällt.
Und dann wieder
quasi versicherungspflichtig wird.
Das geht.
Ich glaube, du bist 55 oder so.
Das funktioniert.
Zurzeit zumindest noch.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
ich habe keine Ambitionen da irgendwie
zurückzugehen.
Ich bezahle auch extra ein bisschen mehr im Monat,
dass ich
dass besonders viel
wegfällt dann im Alter.
Sodass das eigentlich passt.
Also ich kann dir nur empfehlen
einfach anzufangen.
Ich habe das auch letztes Jahr
im August gemacht.
Was mich persönlich sehr motiviert hat,
also ich habe mir kein Motivationsvideo
irgendwie auf YouTube oder so angeguckt.
Was mich persönlich sehr motiviert hat ist,
ich habe mir so eine
Fitness-Tracker-Uhr gekauft.
Und habe damit angefangen einfach mal so ganz
normale Spaziergänge zu tracken.
Und irgendwann hatte ich das
Bedürfnis mal zu gucken,
wie weit kann ich eigentlich rennen
so im jetzigen Zustand.
Und da habe ich es auch nur irgendwie
3 Kilometer oder so geschafft
und war dann komplett im Arsch.
Aber ich dachte mir so,
hey das ging ja besser als gedacht.
Und bin dann einfach weiter gerannt.
Und mittlerweile ist es so, dass ich eigentlich
jeden Tag rennen gehe.
Oder alternativ
ab und zu auch Fahrrad fahren gehe.
Manchmal mache ich einen Tag Pause,
wenn mir die Beine wehtun.
Also manchmal ist es so,
das kann man gar nicht so richtig festmachen,
zu welchen
Aktionen das ist, aber
manchmal weiß ich nicht,
weil ich den Vortag noch nicht so gut verkraftet.
Und ich merke das dann
beim Auftreten,
dass mir irgendwie noch ein bisschen die Beine wehtun.
Dann mache ich manchmal einen Tag Pause.
Das kommt noch nicht mal.
Ich würde sagen, dass es noch nicht mal
einmal die Woche vorkommt,
sondern vielleicht so alle 10 Tage
oder so mal einen Tag Pause.
Deine Meinung zu Stop Killing Games?
Kenne ich nicht.
Ist das so etwas wie Killerspiele?
Oder meinen die,
dass man aufhören soll,
dass Spiele gekillt werden?
So nach dem Motto,
alle Spiele werden abgeschaltet oder was?
Schuhe!
Achso, ja Schuhe habe ich.
Ich habe zwei Paar,
aber ich verwende nur ein Paar.
Ich habe mir zwei gekauft,
aber die einen waren nicht so nice.
Ich verwende,
da muss ich mir auch wieder neue kaufen jetzt,
die sind langsam aber sicher schon ausgelatscht.
Ich habe hier,
äh,
wie heißen diese Dinger?
Nicht ASCII, ASICS.
Hier, die Dinger, genau.
Die Teile habe ich.
ASCII.
ASCII Art.
Die Dinger sind nichts für
Schnellrennen,
also wenn du jetzt wirklich
irgendwie an irgendeinem Wettrennen
teilnehmen willst,
sind das nicht die richtigen Schuhe.
Das sind aber
gute Schuhe für
längere Streckenrennen,
weil man ein bisschen dicker ist.
Weil die haben halt,
ich weiß nicht was das ist,
zwei Zentimeter oder so,
so eine gepolsterte Sohle.
Und das ist sehr angenehm.
Also ich habe das auch
direkt im Vergleich,
am Anfang bin ich ja gerannt
mit meinen ganz normalen Turnschuhen,
die hatten halt keinerlei irgendwie
großartige Dämpfung.
Und da haben mir übelst
die Waden und alles
und das Schienbein vor allem wehgetan.
Das habe ich auch nicht geübt,
das kommt jetzt noch dabei.
Aber mit denen ist das viel angenehmer.
Mit denen ist es wirklich nice.
Fresh Farbe.
Und das Gute ist,
die Schuhe gibt es auch in
Weit.
Ich glaube ich werde,
es gibt jetzt davon
den Nachfolger,
ich glaube 26 wird der Nachfolger
dann sein.
Und den werde ich mir wahrscheinlich
dieses Jahr dann holen,
wenn die da sind.
Updaten die gerade ihre Seite?
Die haben gerade ihre Seite geupdatet,
okay.
Der Loadbalancer hat verkackt,
ja, sieht so aus.
Ich weiß noch nicht,
was ich mir da dieses Jahr für eine...
By the way, das Umschalten
funktioniert nicht.
Ja, aber der ist nice.
Ich bin am überlegen,
ob ich mir nicht noch ein anderes Paar kaufe,
welche die nicht so krass gefedert sind,
weil ich mir wirklich mal ein bisschen,
bisschen Gas geben will.
Aber für meine Zwecke passt das.
Und man muss echt sagen,
man glaubt das gar nicht,
wie
gut man innerhalb von einem Jahr
in was werden kann,
wenn man es einfach regelmäßig macht.
Viel besser als man denkt.
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass ich mal 13 km am Stück rennen kann
und danach nicht ins Krankenhaus muss.
Ich kann heute 13 km
und wahrscheinlich sogar noch eine Ecke mehr rennen.
Und danach,
ich merke schon, dass das anstrengend war
und ich merke das auch schon
in den Beinen, aber es ist nicht so,
als müsste ich den restlichen Tag quasi
am Sauerstoffgerät im Bett verbringen.
Mir geht es danach
eigentlich ganz normal.
Ich setze mich dann mal kurz hin,
esse irgendwie 1-2 Plätzchen,
um ein bisschen Energie aufzufüllen und trinke was
und dann ist es wieder gut.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich
mein Ziel. Ich möchte demnächst,
weil es war nicht ganz so krass heiß,
die letzten Tage war immer wieder super heiß
und
wenn gutes Wetter ist,
nicht ganz so heiß,
dann ist mein Ziel von Hanau
nach Seligenstadt und zurück zu rennen.
Das sind so 21-22 km.
Ich bin sehr zuversichtlich,
da ich das packe.
Das längste, was ich bisher gerannt bin,
waren 14 km, irgendwie so in dem Dreh
14,3 km oder sowas.
Und das ging eigentlich
ohne Probleme. War danach ein bisschen immer.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen ging es.
Und deswegen
ist mein nächstes Ziel
mal 20 km.
Ja, okay, das ist natürlich heftig.
Ich kriege wahrscheinlich nichts gehoben.
Aber das ist auch Übungssache. Vieles.
Es ist unglaublich, wie gut man in was werden kann,
wenn man einfach nur dranbleibt.
Natürlich muss man auch was finden,
also das klappt nur, wenn man was findet,
wo man Spaß dran hat.
Wenn man jedes Mal kotzen muss, wenn man irgendwas macht,
dann wird man es nicht lange machen
und auch nicht dranbleiben.
Man muss schon das Richtige finden für einen selbst.
Für manch einen ist es Rennen,
für manch einen ist es Fahrradfahren,
für manch einen ist es Gewichtsheben,
für manch einen ist es Rudern, keine Ahnung.
Aber wenn man was gefunden hat
und das Bock macht,
dann ist es deutlich einfacher, da dran zu bleiben.
Es ist mittlerweile so,
dass wenn ich wirklich mal
1-2 Tage nicht rennen konnte,
weil, keine Ahnung,
weil ich den einen Tag nach Frankfurt fahren musste
und dann erst nachmittags
am Start war
oder am nächsten Tag
so krass scheißes Wetter ist,
dass es nicht geht,
also wenn ich wirklich 2 Tage am Stück nicht dran bin,
da wäre ich hüppelig,
wie man so schön in Hessen sagt.
Da wäre ich nervös.
Es ist schon ein Stück, ganz ehrlich.
11 km
ist schon
eine Strecke.
Das ist auch eine Sache,
die habe ich auch gemerkt,
wenn man so krass übertreibt,
hat man keinen Bock.
Man hat nicht nur keinen Bock,
das nächste Mal wieder zu rennen zu gehen,
man ist auch nicht richtig erholt genug
bis zum nächsten Mal rennen gehen.
Wenn man jedes Mal rennt bis zum Umfallen,
so nach dem Motto
und ich will heute wieder eine Sekunde besser sein
und wieder eine Sekunde besser
und wieder eine Sekunde besser,
das geht ja irgendwie gar nicht.
Du bist ja relativ schnell schneller als der Weltrekord,
wenn du jeden Tag eine Sekunde schneller bist
als den Tag vorher.
Erstens fuckt es dich ab
und zweitens ist es viel besser,
wenn du regelmäßig rennen gehst,
anstatt nur zweimal die Woche
und dafür richtig brutal.
Zweimal die Woche richtig brutal
stinkt ab gegen
sechsmal die Woche
semischnell.
Natürlich ist die beste Kombination,
man rennt ein bisschen vielfältig,
also man rennt
durchaus mal
achtmal eine Minute schnell,
zehn Minuten einrennen, achtmal eine Minute
schnell mit ein bisschen Pause dazwischen,
zehn Minuten ausrennen, dann läuft man mal
langsamer, eineinhalb Stunden,
also ein bisschen Variationen
sind schon nice, aber im Großen und Ganzen
würde ich sagen, auf lange Sicht
ist derjenige, der sechsmal
die Woche
üben geht,
ohne sich immer komplett zu verausgaben,
nach einem halben Jahr deutlich fitter als der,
der zweimal die Woche geht und immer kurz
vorm Sauerstoffzelt ist.
Also
ich hab noch nix, irgendwie
vielleicht, weiß ich nicht,
noch nix davon gemerkt, also
was ich gemerkt habe ist, wobei das nix damit
zu tun hat, glaube ich, was ich gemerkt habe ist,
was enorm wichtig ist, dass man
sich ordentlich einläuft und aufwärmt.
Das ist echt ein riesen Unterschied.
Ich habe am Anfang oft den Fehler gemacht,
ich bin vor's
Hoftor gegangen
und hab die Uhr angemacht
und bin losgerannt.
Und da hab ich dann schon relativ schnell gemerkt,
hab ich mir gedacht, Alter, drückt aber
schon ganz schön so in Brust
und Halsschlag, Ader und Bein
und so, hab ich gedacht, boah, also, pff,
haut schon gut rein.
Wenn ich aber die
gleiche Geschwindigkeit renne,
nachdem ich vorher ne Viertelstunde
normal eingelaufen bin,
ist überhaupt kein Problem mehr.
Also ich würde selbst, wenn ich jetzt
sagen würde,
ey, ich will mal gucken, wie schnell
ich mittlerweile fünf Kilometer packe,
also wenn ich mal wirklich so all out fünf Kilometer
rennen würde, dann würde ich auch nicht sagen,
oh, ich spare Energie
und bewege mich nicht und renne dann fünf Kilometer,
sondern
ich würde auf jeden Fall
ne Viertelstunde
gemächlich
so, keine Ahnung,
bisschen schneller, bisschen langsamer
mich einrennen,
mal zum Schluss ne Runde sprinten,
sodass man auf Betriebstemperatur ist
und dann die fünf Kilometer rennen.
Und damit fahre ich
höchstwahrscheinlich besser.
Hast du Knieschmerzen? Nein, hab ich nicht.
Das ist auch schon gut.
So hab ich auch angefangen, vor ein paar Jahren.
Einfach jeden Tag ne Stunde
spazieren gegangen.
Bisschen zügig.
Das ist, im Vergleich zu
einfach gar nichts machen, schon mal
mindestens doppelt so gut.
Du gehst von
dir tut der Rücken weh,
dir tut der Arsch weh, Gachi Bass,
du hast Kopfschmerzen,
du hast Nackenverspannungen,
du hast Kreislaufprobleme, alles
geht das
von ner Stunde spazieren
am Tag weg.
Wenn du
diese ganzen Probleme hast,
einfach nur vom PC sitzen,
die gehen weg. Einfach nur vom Laufen.
Ne Stunde am Tag spazieren gehen,
reicht aus.
Und man fühlt sich viel besser.
Man hat kaum noch
Kreislaufsachen, kaum noch Rückenprobleme,
kaum noch Kopfschmerzen, nix mehr.
Es macht immer Sinn.
Es macht immer Sinn,
jeden Tag 80%
zum Laufen zu gehen, anstatt
zweimal die Woche 100%.
Was natürlich noch Sinn macht ist,
wenn du
den Großteil
deiner
Läufe tatsächlich
nur easy rennst
und 20%
oder 10%, 15, 15, 20%
dann schnell. Das ist natürlich
ne super Kombination.
Aber du wirst immer auf lange
Wege fahren.
Du wirst nicht besser fahren
mit mehr als zweimal die Woche
bis zum Umkippen.
Ja hat er.
Und Biom suckt.
Das habe ich in ner Viertelstunde
Ich will nicht sagen, dass es suckt.
Aber ich kann es für meinen Anwendungszweck
nicht verwenden.
Was doof ist.
Eigentlich wollte ich das heute ausprobieren
ein bisschen länger als ne Viertelstunde.
Aber was willst du machen?
Was ich machen werde ist,
ich habe ja ne GoPro mittlerweile am Start
und so ein
so ein Ding, wo man sich die GoPro umhängen kann
wenn ich die 22 Kilometer
renne
nach Seligenstadt hin und zurück
das nehme ich vielleicht mit der GoPro auf
und lass da irgendwie so ein 10 Minuten Video
draus schneiden.
Zwischendurch werde ich ab und zu mal ein bisschen
versuchen was zu sagen.
Einfach um zu zeigen, dass man das mit ein bisschen Übung
auch als übelstes Kellerkind
das 24 7 vorm Computer sitzt
hinkriegen kann
wenn man sich ein bisschen Mühe gibt.
Ne, also wie gesagt ich habe keine
Knieschmerzen. Das einzige
was ich am Anfang hatte ist
mir haben ziemlich die Schienbeine weh getan.
Aber da hat sich nix entzündet
oder so. Also ich habe hier schon irgendwelche Horrorstories
im Chat gesehen von
ja was weiß ich
gebrochenes
gebrochene
irgendwie
Schienbeine zu entzünden.
Bündungen, dass du nicht mehr auftreten kannst
nix. Hatte ich gar nix.
Mir hat das Schienbein weh getan
und das lag einfach da dran.
Das lag wahrscheinlich an mehreren Sachen. Erstens ganz am Anfang
weil ich mit scheiß Schuhen gelaufen bin
und weil ich zu schwer bin
und
weil ich es nicht gewöhnt bin.
Ja, ganz einfach.
Und umso mehr ich
jetzt gerannt bin in den richtigen
Schuhen und umso mehr ich insgesamt
gerannt bin und ich bin ja auch mittlerweile noch
ein paar Kilo leichter geworden.
Jetzt habe ich überhaupt keine Probleme mehr.
Es ist jetzt bei mir so
wenn ich loslaufe
dann merke ich so die ersten 500 Meter noch
so
ich merke es noch ein bisschen von gestern in den Beinen
aber nach 500 Meter ist es weg.
Deswegen ist ja unter anderem
der Grund warum ich
froh bin, dass ich noch
vor 40 angefangen habe mit Rennen und Fahrradfahren
da bleibt mir das alles wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
erspart noch. Ja.
Wie gesagt Schienbein
ist normal. Hatte ich am Anfang auch.
Du brauchst gescheite Schuhe.
Das ist das allerwichtigste.
Du brauchst gedämpfte Schuhe.
So ein Ding hier zum Beispiel was ich vorhin gezeigt habe
hier. Nicht unbedingt den
das ist ja der andere.
Ja, ich habe doch den alten.
Den hier zum Beispiel. Kann ich persönlich empfehlen
habe ich auch.
Und dadurch, dass die Schuhe hier so
viel, irgendwie so 2 cm
Schaum drunter haben ist das viel viel
angenehmer. Du haust gar nicht
so sehr drauf aufs Schienbein.
Also das bringt enorm was.
Sich ein bisschen Mühe zu geben
ordentlich aufzutreten.
So ein bisschen, dass man ein bisschen Mühe
gibt, dass man mehr in der Mitte auftritt. Bringt auch was.
Aber was am meisten
bringt ist tatsächlich. Mir wird das kaum
glauben. Übung.
Also umso länger du das machst
umso weniger tut es weh.
Deswegen am Anfang auch nicht
komplett übertreiben.
Ja also wenn du losläufst
und es tut beim nächsten Tag loslaufen
noch so weh, dass du nicht richtig
weiterlaufen kannst. Dann mach auf jeden Fall Pause.
Nicht übertreiben.
Was tatsächlich auch gut ist
hat schon einer im Chat geschrieben.
Wenn du nicht gerade auf
sehr hartem Untergrund läufst.
Waldwege sind sicherlich besser.
Und angenehmer.
Klar das hilft richtig.
Das hilft.
Deswegen ist es auch
nice wenn man ein bisschen
variiert was man macht.
Weil der Körper gewöhnt sich relativ schnell
immer die gleichen Sachen.
Deswegen finde ich es ganz nice.
Ich habe hier so eine Garmin Uhr.
Und da kann man so ein Trainingsprogramm
anmachen.
Und das schickt einem
jeden Tag wenn man
Rennen als Sportler auswählt.
Schlägt es einem jeden Tag vor
was man machen soll. Da stehen dann zum Beispiel
so Sachen drin wie.
Also morgen soll ich beispielsweise
1 Stunde 27 rennen.
Danach
49 Minuten. Also immer unterschiedliche Geschwindigkeiten.
49 Minuten, 49 Minuten.
Dann 42 Minuten aber
eine ganze Ecke schneller. Wieder 49 Minuten.
Dann 30 Minuten zum erholen.
Dann 50 Minuten.
8 mal 1 Minute
schneller.
Das ist ganz nice.
Dann macht man dann immer das gleiche.
Und übt auch ein bisschen
unterschiedliches Zeug.
Am besten ist natürlich wenn man irgendwelche Wege
bei sich in der Nähe hat.
Also ich laufe zum Beispiel
mittlerweile auch.
So eine Runde hier.
Ich laufe ein Stückchen durchs Ort.
In den Wald rein.
Im nächsten Ort.
Und dort dann am Main wieder zurück.
Das ist so 50 50.
Das ist so 50% Waldweg und 50%
halt so Gehweg und Straße.
Das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Ja. So sieht es aus.
Und mittlerweile
bin ich da selbst immer wieder begeistert
wie gut das alles funktioniert.
Ich lebe mitten auf dem
Hügel. Also muss ich immer den Berg hoch.
Ich kann dir nur empfehlen wenn du anfängst.
Renn nicht zu schnell den Berg runter.
Ich habe das gemerkt.
Gerade am Anfang wo ich auch
immer wieder Schmerzen in den Schienbeinen hatte.
Die Stellen
wo sich das am meisten quasi
in Schienbeinen gehämmert hat ist
2 mal die Brücke runter
laufen. Nicht die Brücke hoch.
2 mal die Brücke runter laufen.
Schnell.
Und da ging es halt relativ steil.
Und wenn dir das schnell runter läuft
das hämmert sowas von auf die Schienbeine.
Bis ich es dann irgendwann mal gecheckt habe.
Und einfach
die Brücke runter gelaufen bin.
Einfach runter rollen.
Five head time.
Ich bin an die Brücke runter gelaufen.
Mittlerweile ist kein Ding mehr.
Mittlerweile bin ich das gewohnt genug.
Ja.
Naja.
Insgesamt
es lohnt sich einfach weil man ein bisschen was macht.
Man muss nicht rennen. Man muss nicht Fahrrad fahren.
Einfach spazieren gehen reicht schon.
Eine Stunde am Tag spazieren gehen
ist der perfekte Ausgleich für
24 7 Rechner hocken.
Man kann ja dann auch gar nicht mehr 24 7
vorm Rechner hocken.
Weil man sich eine Stunde draußen ein bisschen bewegt.
Oder kann man nur noch 23 7 vorm Rechner hocken.
Reicht ja auch noch.
Ohne Scheiß Leute. Es ist zwar nur eine Stunde Unterschied.
Aber 23 7
vorm Rechner hocken
und eine Stunde spazieren gehen am Tag
ist um ein Vielfaches gesünder als 24 7
vorm Rechner hocken.
Und dann bist du kein Fahrradfahrer.
Ab und zu schon.
Also ich habe ein Fahrrad.
Und ich fahre öfters Fahrrad.
Aber ich fahre in letzter Zeit nicht so oft Fahrrad.
Weil sich das nachmittags nicht lohnt.
Wie gesagt unter 2 Stunden
habe ich keinen Bock Fahrrad zu fahren.
Also ich würde sagen
aktuell ist es so
dass ich
sagen wir mal 80% renne
und 20% Fahrrad fahre.
Ich mache das mit dem Fahrrad fahren.
Ich fahre Fahrrad fahren ganz gerne
an Tagen wo ich merke
boah ich habe noch den Lauf von gestern in den Beinen.
Dann fahre ich auch mal ganz gerne Fahrrad.
Dann kann man die Beine ein bisschen
das Schienbein
und so ein bisschen schonen.
Dafür tut dir deine Oberschenkel weh.
Aber Fahrrad fahren hätte ich auch nicht gedacht.
Ich bin ja
Jahre, Jahrzehnte kein Fahrrad mehr gefahren.
Fahrrad fahren ist
macht Spaß.
Macht einfach Spaß.
Das ist genau die richtige Sportart.
Das habe ich schon öfters gesagt.
Also Fahrrad fahren noch besser als rennen
für wenn es stressig gewesen ist.
Also Fahrrad fahren ist genau die richtige Sportart
für
das ist anstrengend
man kann es auch so übertreiben
dass man danach umkippt.
Aber ich meine so normal
einfach mal ein bisschen
eine Runde fahren.
Das ist anstrengend genug
weil man sich nicht bemübeln kann
und sich Gedanken macht.
Aber es ist auch nicht so anstrengend
wenn man normal fährt
dass man an nichts mehr denken kann.
Also Fahrrad fahren ist genau die richtige
wenn man einfach normal fährt
genau so die richtige
Belastung.
Ich übertreibe es manchmal
gerade bei uns hier in der Ecke
ich habe eine Standardrunde
die geht ungefähr 2 Stunden
bisschen länger 2 Stunden 15
und
da geht es
so ungefähr
sagen wir mal
so ein Viertel der Zeit
geht es da
geht es da berghoch
also so eine halbe Stunde
nicht super krass berghoch
es geht
relativ
gemächlich berghoch
und dann geht es mal so
würde ich sagen
10 Minuten
15 Minuten
ich sage mal es geht 40 Minuten
berghoch aber
eine Viertelstunde richtig ordentlich
und da kann ich es immer nicht lassen
selbst wenn ich mir im Vorfeld vornehme
Max fahr einfach entspannt hoch
ich kriege das nicht hin
sobald ich merke dass es den Bash hoch geht
ich muss einfach
voll rein treten
es ist total dämlich
ich kann ohne Probleme einfach langsamer fahren
es wäre zwar immer noch anstrengend
aber seitdem ich jetzt
quasi so Pedale mit
Wattmesser drin habe
wo man quasi gucken kann
was man so an Leistungsoutput hat
da mache ich gerade bei kleinen
bei kleinen Anstiegen
da muss ich immer sehen dass da irgendwie
450 Watt oder sowas draufsteht
das kann man nicht lange
nicht das ihr denkt ich habe
super irgendwie
3km breite Oberschenkel
oder so
für kurze Strecken
den Berg hoch
so 15-20 Sekunden kann man das immer machen
länger nicht
ja genau
wenn es da mal wirklich kurz ein bisschen schneller geht
da kannst du volle Pulle so 450
500 Watt
das kann ich auch nicht lange
wenn ich das länger mache als die kurzen Anstiege
da falle ich vom Fahrrad
aber da kann ich mich
nicht zurück halten
ich könnte die auch langsam fahren
aber da muss ich immer volle Pulle reintreten
und dann geht es ein bisschen länger den Berg hoch
so eine viertel Stunde
geht es dann relativ steil den Berg hoch
auf dem Berg oben ist eine Pizzeria
ich habe mir auch schon gedacht
irgendwann wenn ich es mal zu sehr übertrieben habe
stelle ich da einfach mein Fahrrad ab
und fresse eine Pizza bevor ich weiter fahre
da ist eine Pizzeria oben
und
da übertreibe ich es auch immer
also diese 15
diese 15-20 Minuten
da gucke ich auch permanent
immer auf meinen Wattcounter
so nach dem Motto
unter 200
darf das nicht fallen
volle Pulle
und 200 ist für Noobs wie uns
oder Noobs wie mich
ist das wirklich ordentlich
tretet mal eine Viertelstunde 200 Watt
das wirkt
zwar nicht viel am Anfang
aber glaubt mir
wenn ihr das eine Viertelstunde oder 20 Minuten treten muss
dann ist das
nicht ohne
kann ich euch sagen
das geht ganz schön in die Beine
drunter machen wir es ja nicht
naja
sag mal
also seit ich
diese Anzeige habe für
diese Leistungsmessung
ist das
nicht unbedingt die gesündeste
Art dadurch wie ich jetzt fahre
würde ich sagen
weil das geht schon ordentlich auf die Beine
oder auf die Knie oder alles
aber man will
einfach die ordentlichen
Wattwerte dann auf seinem
Computer stehen haben
hast du einen Minicomputer
ja habe ich habe ich
ich habe so einen Garmin Tracker
von Garmin so einen Tracker
wobei ich habe beides dran
ich habe einen Garmin Tracker dran
und mein Handy
mein Handy habe ich zur Navigation dran
weil die Navigation auf dem Handy einfach mal
3000%
besser ist
als auf diesem Garmin Ding
das Ding wird ja verkauft als
Fahrradcomputer Schrägstrich
Navigationsgerät
und du kannst mit dem Garmin Ding auch
Navigieren das ist so ein Teil hier
Garmin
ja
die machen sogar Werbung damit
dass du hier Navigieren kannst aber ganz ehrlich
du kannst damit Navigieren
und du kommst auch an das funktioniert
aber das Ding hat 1 FPS
das ist super lahm
im Vergleich zum Handy
schlecht aufgelöst und klein
also wenn ich Strecken fahre die ich nicht so gut
kenne
dann fahre ich immer mit dem Handy
als Navigationsgerät zusätzlich
aber so ein Ding habe ich auch dran
zum Anzeigen von allen möglichen Werten
wie viele Kilometer ich schon gefahren bin
wie gerade die Steigung ist
wie meine Herzfrequenz ist
wie viel Watt ich gerade in die Pedale trete
das zeige ich alles
auf dem Garmin an
vom Handy habe ich Komod auf
mit Routenplanung
das kann ich einfach an
in der Mitte vom Lenker
da wo der Lenker quasi als Fahrrad geschraubt ist
da kann man die Schraube austauschen
und quasi als
als Kappe da drauf
so eine Halterung setzen fürs Handy
drehe ich einfach das Handy rein
und wenn ich es nicht brauche kann ich das Handy in die Tasche stecken
ne?
das macht einen Unterschied
gerade wenn du beispielsweise
durch Dörfer oder
Straßen Navigieren musst
die du nicht kennst
ein Navigationsgerät
was schnell ist und ordentlich reagiert
und sich dreht
wenn du um die Kurve fährst
und nicht erst irgendwie 3 Sekunden später
ist viel einfacher zu Navigieren
als mit dem Garmin
sonst würde ich es ja nicht machen
Wattmessungspedale sind teuer
ich habe auch nur die Billigvariante
ich habe nur die einseitige Variante
ich habe mir immer überlegt
ob ich nicht umsteige auf
nicht wirklich Kurbel
ja doch Kurbel
ja
also nicht eingebaut sondern auch auf Kurbel
Wattmessungsdinger umsteige
weil ich mit diesen Garmin
Clipsdinger nicht so
ganz zufrieden bin
die quietschen öfters mal die musst du laufend ölen
dass die nicht quietschen
das ist ein bekanntes Problem
bei diesen Garmin Wattmessungspedalen
machst du ab und zu Öl drauf
aber viel öfters als man eigentlich denkt
dass man drauf müsste
das ist in meinem Fahrrad nicht
weil mein Fahrrad läuft
zumindest was die Kette angeht
mit Kettenwachs und nicht mit Öl
aber man kann man trotzdem
an die Pedale machen
deswegen habe ich mir auch schon überlegt
ob ich nicht tatsächlich
ganz normale Pedale
dran mache zum reinklipsen
und
so eine Kurbel
Wattmessung
ja genau so ein Ding
zu kaufen
es ist auch nur einseitig
aber du musst im Endeffekt
nur den Arm austauschen
ja beste
ok
jetzt übelst krass Sidetracked random Zeug
aber ich find's nice
dass ihr da schon
ähnliche Erfahrungen gemacht habt
ahja und
wow
Dankeschön
5 Milliarden Alter
Dankeschön für die Bits
ähm
äh
vergessen was ich sagen wollte
ahja Fahrradwege
Fahrradwege sind in Deutschland echt kacke
also ich habe ja schon öfters erlebt
dass die Sachen
so undurchsichtig
oder gar nicht ausgeschildert waren
dass du einfach nicht durchblickst
und das nächste ist
dass die Fahrradwege selbst
oftmals in sehr schlechtem Zustand sind
also du hast Wurzel drunter durch
dass es permanent
huppelt
ja du hast ähm
wenn es durch irgendwelche Dörfer geht
manchmal den Gehweg nicht richtig abgesenkt
obwohl ein Fahrradweg lang geht dazwischen
musst du teilweise bremsen
dass du dir nicht irgendwie das Rad kaputthaust
ja dann hast du gescherte
gescherte Wege
wo es dann irgendwelche Leute im Auto
nicht abwarten können
und dich an ganz doofen Stellen überholen müssen
ich fahr sehr ungern auf Strecken wo auch Autos fahren
mag vielleicht daran liegen
dass mich
wenn ich noch nicht so lange Fahrrad gefahren bin
wieder gleich jemand umgefahren hat
ich bin mir zu Glück
ist mir nichts passiert
also wenn du regelmäßig fährst
ist das eines der besten Sachen überhaupt
weil du kannst ja sonst gar nicht
richtig tracken
wie gut du bist
und wie du dich verbessert hast
und schwer nachzuvollziehen
ohne
Wattmessungspedale
oder irgendeine Art der
Leistungsmessung
wenn du einfach nur
just for fun rumfährst
und dich das nicht interessiert
ist das auch okay
muss ja nicht jeder
ich bin spannend
ich mag alles mögliche an Technik und auch am Fahrrad
und ich hab gerne auf meinem Computer 800 verschiedene Werte
die ich mir angucken kann während ich fahre
ansonsten wenn man ein bisschen
gucken will
wo läufts gut
was liegt einem so
wie hat man sich verbessert
ist Leistungsmessung finde ich schon sehr sinnig am Fahrrad
weil es unglaublich motivierend ist
zu sehen
dass die Pfeile
ne finde ich nicht dass das reicht
es sei denn
du fährst jedes mal immer die gleiche
die gleiche Strecke
wenn du jedes mal immer die gleiche Strecke fährst
okay
dann vielleicht aber ansonsten
ist es gerade auf dem Fahrrad
weil die Strecken nicht eben sind
die sind unterschiedlich lang
die sind unterschiedliches Profil
ist Geschwindigkeit und Herzfrequenz finde ich nicht alleine aussagekräftig
und was ein weiterer Vorteil
von Wattmessungspedalen ist
wenn man das trackt
in der App
es kann ein
sehr großer Motivationsboost sein
grüne Pfeile zu sehen
man kennt das
von Youtube Videos
wenn die Views raufgehen und grüne Pfeile sind
genauso ist das in Fitness Tracking Apps auch
wenn euer
was auch immer ihr für einen Wert trackt
wenn der nach oben geht
mit grünen Pfeilen
über mehrere Wochen und Monate
dann ist das einfach sehr motivierend
sich das nächste mal
hinzusetzen und zu sagen
ey auf gehts
heute ist auch scheiß Wetter
aber ich will das die Pfeile weiter grün nach oben gehen
ich habe keine Apple Watch
mir gefällt die Apple Watch nicht so sehr
für reines Sport Tracking
weil die Akkulaufzeit zu kurz ist
insgesamt ist das bestimmt
eine gute Smartwatch
Niederlande muss nice sein
in Belgien angeblich auch
hier sind die Fahrradwege etwas pepeger
was mir auch schon aufgefallen ist
dass du Fahrradwege hast wo sich die Schilder widersprechen
also nach dem Motto
Fahrradfahrer absteigen hier Fahrradweg
ja wie jetzt
was denn jetzt
also Fußgänger meckern
hatte ich auch schon
also eigentlich bisher nur ein Opa
der mal übelst gemeckert hat
aber ansonsten ist das vollkommen in Ordnung gewesen
ich fahre meistens
Strecken wo nicht so viel los ist
also schon gar nicht Autos
auf meiner
Standardstrecke gibt es nur
ganz kleines Stück
durchs Ort wo theoretisch Autos fahren könnten
da sind aber wenig Autos
weil das ein ganz kleines Kaff ist
und äh
das erste Stück von dem steileren
Anstieg hoch den Berg
ist auch noch Straße durchs Ort
aber das ist auch so ein kleines Kaff
da fährt es so gut wie nix
und danach geht es in den Wald
rein
und da ist da ab und zu ein paar Fußgänger im Wald
die da spazieren gehen
ist da eigentlich auch nix
das ist echt ne gute Strecke
so ungefähr 2 Stunden 15
weiß gar nicht
wieviel 42 km oder sowas
42 km
es schwankt auch immer
ein bisschen wie lang es dauert
je nachdem
ob die Bahnschranke zu ist oder nicht
ja sadge
Fahrradwege sind teilweise übelst scheiß
Zustand
also ich fahr ja auch immer ein Stück durch den Wald
am Anfang
und danach wieder
und es wechselt immer ab
und das sind wirklich brutalste Schlaglöcher
im Fahrradweg
wenn du da nicht wirklich sehr
vorausschauend guckst
und fährst
landest du echt auch mal schnell in irgendeinem Schlagloch
ja und
das Problem ist
dass es gibt 2 Sachen
die vertragen sich nicht gut
wirklich
schnell und anstrengend fahren
und
bei klarem Verstand
vorausschauend gucken
das sind Sachen die klappen nicht gut zusammen
weil umso anstrengender es ist
umso schlechter ist es vorausschauend zu gucken
weil es halt einfach anstrengend ist
deswegen ist es ganz gut
wenn man die Strecke kennt
also bei mir bei dieser einen Strecke durch den Wald
weiß ich schon ok da ist es wieder voller Schlaglöcher
hast du dir mal Dashcams
fürs Fahrrad angesehen?
ja hab ich, ich hab sogar ne Halterung
ich hab sogar ne GoPro Halterung
vorne, weil ich mir gedacht hab
ich kann mal irgendwann einfach ne Runde aufnehmen
und als Hintergrundmaterial für ein Video verwenden
wenn ich einfach nur schwätze und gerade kein Gameplay hab
ja
ich kann da entweder ne GoPro dran machen
oder irgendwas anderes
hab ich
und für
nach hinten hab ich keine Dashcam
sondern nach hinten hab ich
ein von Garmin so nen Radar
das zeigt einem an wenn Autos von hinten kommen
und äh
kann auch als Rücklicht fungieren
welches Fahrrad?
ähm mach mal Ausrufezeichen Fahrrad
ja das da hab ich
boah meine Auge alter
das müssen wir jetzt mal kurz mit
Dark Reader aufmachen
boah ey what the
ah yes
meine Güte
das hier
der Preis stimmt nicht
ich habs gekauft für ungefähr
2300 Euro
weil das das Modell aus dem letzten Jahr ist
und ich noch
glaube das letzte gekriegt hab
in meiner Größe
das ist mehr oder weniger das Fahrrad
bisschen anders
aber mehr oder weniger das Fahrrad was ich auch vorm Unfall hatte
und
ich dachte mir so ey weißt du was
nachdem ich jetzt schon
von dem ganzen Kram eh mehr Geld
wieder kriege
als mich das Fahrrad gekostet hat
und ich die Möglichkeit hab
das Fahrrad noch günstiger zu bekommen
dann bestell ich das gleich
also wie gesagt die Versicherung hat ja bei mir ewig gebraucht
bis sie das bezahlt haben nach dem
Unfall das war nicht schrittig oder so
es war von Anfang an klar das die Autofahrerin
schuld war an der ganzen Geschichte
die haben auch gesagt ja ja passt wir übernehmen das
die haben 10 Monate oder so gebraucht
ewig gebraucht das alles zu bezahlen
und am Ende ist es halt sehr teuer geworden
für die Versicherung weil
Gutachterkosten bei mir
Anwaltkosten bei mir
plus Ausfallkosten
oder wie auch immer man das genau nennt ja
die haben ja am Ende
fast das Doppelte überwiesen
von dem was das Fahrrad ursprünglich gekostet hat
wollen sie noch immer Geld zurück
ja die haben so jetzt muss ich euch mal vorstellen
die haben am Ende sogar zu viel überwiesen
und wollten 80 Euro noch zurück haben
allein schon das Anschreiben
und Bearbeiten und Weiterleiten
von meinem Anwalt an mich dass ich 80 Euro
das war schon teurer für die wieder
als die 80 Euro zu dem was gebracht hat
also die sind echt
die haben sich echt dumm angestellt
man würde fast vermuten
es ist Taktik
um die Leute mürbe zu machen
aber was willst du da mürbe machen
ich habe nur über den Anwalt mit denen kommuniziert
und er lässt ja nicht einfach locker nur weil die lahm sind
der freut sich weil er für jeden Brief
und jeden Furz den er lässt noch extra Geld kriegt
also die waren echt
bescheuert bei der Versicherung
die waren richtig dumm
richtige PP-Gas
ja und ich habe mir das neue Fahrrad
gekauft bevor ich das Geld
komplett zurück hatte
und da dachte ich mir so ey
ich meine ich kriege eh schon mehr Geld
zurück
und das Fahrrad
ist quasi jetzt reduziert
2.300 Euro
nur noch
dann bestelle ich doch das letzte Modell auch wenn es
vom Vorjahr ist was juckt es mich denn
ob es vom Vorjahr ist oder nicht
das Fahrrad ist immer noch super
ich habe ein paar Sachen gemoddet dran wieder
das ein bisschen mehr ist wie das alte
ja ich habe hier Tasche noch
dran gemacht und ich habe einen anderen
anderen
Ritzelpaket
so hinten drauf gemacht
da ich ein bisschen
leichteren Gang noch habe
ansonsten
nichts geändert dran
sonst wunderbar
Ende des Jahres muss ich auf jeden Fall
die Reifen tauschen
die sind dann wahrscheinlich ziemlich abgefahren
bis dahin
aber nices Fahrrad
macht echt Spaß
wie hoch ist deine FDP
ich kann es dir nicht genau sagen
weil das letzte Mal wo ich den
FDP Test gemacht habe
war Ende letzten Jahres
auf meinem Home Trainer
und da war er 170
so
nachdem ich aber
bei mir hier öfters
den Berg hoch fahre und das ungefähr
15 bis 20 Minuten Berg hoch geht
und ich
aus irgendwelchen Gründen der Meinung bin
ich darf nicht meine
Wattzahl unter 200 fallen lassen
weil ich sonst zu Noob
mäßig unterwegs bin
und man ja so sagt
95%
von deinen Wattwerten
über 20 Minuten
ist dein FDP
würde ich sagen ist der jetzt wahrscheinlich
so irgendwie bei
Garmin sagt 170
weil es der letzten Test
ist den ich gemacht habe
bei mir autoadjustet das Garmin nicht
ich weiß nicht ob es das macht für FDP
ich habe damals
auf meinem
Heim Wahoo Trainer
so einen FDP Test gemacht
mit 20 Minuten und da kam 170 raus
letztes Jahr
ich gehe davon aus dass ich jetzt
dreiviertel Jahr später ein bisschen besser geworden bin
deswegen könnte das mit 190 schon hinkommen
also
ich will nicht sagen das Garmin das nicht kann
oder so mit dem Auto updaten
aber
bei mir hat es sich dann noch nicht automatisch
aktualisiert das hat immer noch den FDP Wert
von November 2023
dann ist es aber ziemlich dumm wenn sich das Ding auf 800 Watt
adjustet
weil niemand auf der Welt hat
einen FDP von 800 Watt
dreht mal 800 Watt über 20 Minuten
dann wirst du keinen auf der Welt finden der das hinkriegt
noch nicht mal der diesjährige
Tour de France Gewinner oder irgendwelche
Bahnfahrer habe ich
ja habe ich
ja gut Watt pro Kilo kann man dann relativ
einfach ausrechnen ne?
also ich wiege 87 Kilo
und meine Watt pro Kilo
sind dementsprechend
schlecht
also wenn ich sagen wir mal wirklich
ich mache irgendwie keine Ahnung
200 Watt über 20 Minuten
und
200 Watt sind halt dann geteilt
durch 87
sind halt nicht so viel ne?
sind halt 2,
naja doch das ist nicht schlecht
das sind
das sind ganz brauchbare Noob Werte
2,3
Watt pro Kilo
das sind relativ gute Noob Werte
das ist nicht super
man darf nicht vergessen
um es jetzt mal wieder
weil ich habe es euch ja am Anfang erzählt
von den 10 Kilometer Läufern
bei Olympischen Spielen
nur mal im Verhältnis
wie krass Profi
Fahrradfahrer sind
bei der Tour de France
sind die Spitzenleute
oder der Gewinner
ist den Berg hoch gefahren mit
6,7
Watt
pro Kilogramm
ja gut ne das
die haben sich auch was reingehauen
höchstwahrscheinlich vorfeld
und zwischenzeitlich sogar über 7
und ich habe 2,2
ja
und das kann ich auch nicht lange machen
also ich kann damit den Berg hochfahren
ich kann den Berg hochfahren ungefähr
so mit so viertel Stunde 20 Minuten
200 Watt
aber die restliche
die restliche Strecke
die ist glücklicherweise
zum größten Teil flach
und da merke ich auch die Beine
von diesen 20 Minuten
der Tour de France Gewinner
wiegt glaube ich
65 Kilo oder so
und der ist irgendwie 1,74
und wiegt keine Ahnung
der ist ziemlich genauso groß wie ich
und wiegt irgendwie
63, 64, 65 Kilo
der ähm
der Gewinner vom Olympischen
Straßenrennen
ist 1,71
und wiegt knapp über 60 Kilo
also das sind
ich bin richtig
Chonker gegen die äh
so ne Tour de France Etappe
geht zwischen
kommt drauf an
so die normalen Etappen gehen so zwischen 100
130, 160
Kilometer
also super krass wie früher
früher sind die teilweise ja 200 plus gegangen
so die meisten die meisten würde ich sagen
sind so irgendwas um 160
oder so mittlerweile
manchmal auch ein bisschen kürzer
je nachdem wie viele Berge und so
ich würde sagen so Durchschnitt
so 160 oder so
weiß ich gar nicht so wie viel
also früher waren die auf jeden Fall länger
da war es ja teilweise schon normaler als über 200
also das Olympische Straßenrennen heute
das war glaube ich 240 Kilometer
oder sowas also die sind ja überstunden
über sieben Stunden gefahren
das ist halt schon heftig
bin mir nicht sicher ich glaube die
die die die Tour de France waren
die wenigsten Etappen über 200
ich bin mir aber ich hab's aber auch nicht mehr genau im Kopf
ja tatsächlich
wo steht das
Etappenlänge
ja Länge
ok 200, 200, 177
naja
komm so so so daneben
hab ich jetzt auch nicht gelegen
so mit 160
ja doch
wobei
ja die Bergen Dinger sind halt deutlich deutlich kürzer
ja aber auch hier eine mit 130 und so
weiß ich was die Durchschnittslänge ist
wo ich persönlich hin will
ich hab ehrlich gesagt
gar keine so großartigen Ziele
ich will einfach weiter grüne Pfeile haben
in der Fitness App die nach oben zeigen
also ich hab
ich hab eigentlich so zwei Ziele was das angeht
aber nicht fürs Fahrradfahren ehrlich gesagt
ähm ich hab
das erste Ziel
22km rennen
Hanau Seligenstadt und zurück
also hin und zurück sind
22km
also quasi Halbmarathon Distanz
will ich einmal rennen in nächster Zeit
bin ich relativ zuversichtlich
da ich das packe
das längste was ich bisher gerannt bin waren 14km
und danach war ich zwar geschafft aber nicht irgendwie
übelst im Arsch
also wenn ich es da nicht übertreibe denke ich packe ich das
und vielleicht sogar auch in einer ganz brauchbaren Zeit
und mein
nächstes Ziel was Rennen angeht
ist endlich mal
mich zusammenreißen und volle Pulle 5km
durchrennen sodass ich unter 25 Minuten bin
ich denke dass das
dass das ganz gut geht
ich renne immer mal wieder
so 8 mal eine Minute
wie nennt das
Garmin
Garmin nennt das
nicht Sprint oder Intervalle
Garmin nennt das immer
ach der hat ein doofes Wort dafür
letztendlich sind das 8 mal eine Minute
halt
schneller
als man so im Durchschnitt rennt
also zum Beispiel muss ich dann
eine Minute
4 Minuten 30 oder sowas rennen
und dann
3 Minuten Pause und dann wieder 1 Minute 4 Minuten 30
und
4 Minuten 30 ist schon echt
anstrengend für mich
aber ich packe das länger als
die Minute die Garmin von mir will
so und
unter
25 Minuten 5km
heißt ja im Endeffekt
du musst unter 5 Minuten
den Kilometer rennen
so und
für mich ist aktuell
vom Pace her
ist 6 Minuten 30
ist ziemlich
angenehm zu rennen
6 Minuten 30
pro Kilometer
also 6 Minuten 30 kann ich auch
13 Kilometer
rennen am Stück
6 Minuten 30 pro Kilometer
das
da bin ich geschafft danach
aber dann tun mir eher die Beine weh
als dass ich kreislaufmäßig im Arsch wäre
6 Minuten 30 pro Kilometer
das ist sehr angenehm
wenn ich
bedeutend langsamer renne kommt es mir so vor
als komme ich nicht vom Fleck
also 6 Minuten 30 ist relativ angenehm für mich
5 Minuten 30
5 Minuten 40
ist schon was wo ich sage ey
das geht
über die Distanz
das könnte ich wenn ich es wirklich drauf anlege
wahrscheinlich auch über 10 Kilometer rennen
aber das ist schon echt
anstrengend dann aber über 5 Kilometer
ist gar kein Problem
über 5 Kilometer so 5 Minuten 30
und so da denke ich mir danach ok
war anstrengend
aber
ich könnte es mit ein bisschen
Pause jetzt nochmal rennen
unter 5 Minuten
da wird es wirklich
anstrengend für mich
also unter 5 Minuten pro Kilometer
so 4.50 oder so
das kann ich eine Weile machen
aber dann wird es wirklich anstrengend
das heißt ich denke
ich würde packen
5 Kilometer zu rennen
knapp unter
5 Minuten
also quasi knapp unter 5 Minuten
aber es wird auf jeden Fall anstrengend
Garmin sagt auch
man hat so einen Race Predictor
in der Garmin Uhr
beziehungsweise in der Garmin App
und mein Race Predictor
sagt
dass ich
5 Minuten und 3 Sekunden
Pace rennen soll
über 5 Kilometer
im Wettrennen
oder kann besser
nicht soll kann
nachdem da immer ein bisschen
plus minus drin ist
würde ich sagen
wenn ich wirklich alles gebe
ist es durchaus drinne
dass ich es unter 25 Minuten packe
und wenn nicht
übe ich halt noch ein paar Wochen
und dann packe ich es unter 25 Minuten
also das ist tatsächlich so
mein Ziel für kürzere Strecken ist
5 Kilometer
unter 25 Minuten
und
dann die Halbmarathon
Distanz nach Hanau
Seligenstadt und zurück
die will ich einfach nur rennen
da habe ich kein spezielles
Goal für
ja ich finde das ist durchaus ok
und da sieht man mal
ich mache das seit einem Jahr
oder ein bisschen über einem Jahr
jetzt
also man kriegt auch in einem Jahr
wenn man dran bleibt
wenn es etwas ist was einem Spaß macht
sonst ist es natürlich mit dran bleiben schwierig
kriegt man echt was hin
auch als 24 7 vom PC Hockkeller Kind wie ich
ja sowas
du wirst lachen
sowas habe ich mir auch überlegt
also
die schicken dir
so eine
so ein Abdruck
die schicken dir so eine Abdruckform
per Post
für deinen Arsch
und da setzt du dich rein in diese Form
und schickst die Form zurück
und die passen dir dann
quasi anhand von deinem
Arschabdruck
3D drucken die dir einen
eigens für dich
angefertigten Sattel
das ist eigentlich richtig nice Technik
kostet
weiß ich nicht was es kostet
aber ich habe mal vor einem Jahr
oder so geguckt
das war im Rahmen
es hat jetzt keine 500 Euro oder so gekostet
also 170 Kilometer Fahrrad fahren
da wird dir auf jeden Fall
der Arsch wehtun
auch wenn du es geübt bist
was soll in dem Fall
Netto und Brutto heißen
verstehe ich jetzt nicht
ach mit und ohne Pause
ach so verstehe
also 170 Kilometer hat dir bestimmt auch dahinter
weh getan
aber es ist gar nicht so wild
also am Anfang hat mir auch extrem der Arsch weh getan
auf dem Fahrrad
aber es ist Gewöhnungssache
weil
wenn man diese klassischen
Sattel gewöhnt ist
also diese die man so kennt
also das sind jetzt natürlich
ja also die Sattel die man so kennt
ja
so diese Dinger und so
die sind zwar komfortabel für
ich fahr mal kurz zum Edeka was einkaufen
wenn du da drüber
so ein richtiger
Oma Fahrrad Sattel quasi
ja
so ein Ding hier
für Senioren extra breit
die sind zwar bequem
wenn du zum Edeka fährst was einkaufen
wenn du damit aber
wahrscheinlich reichen
20-30 Kilometer schon
fährst tut dir der Arsch weh
und das liegt daran
weil du
also erstens wahrscheinlich
nicht die richtige Hose dafür an hast
und weil das reibt
dadurch das das nicht
glatt ist und fest ist
das reibt
du hast dann Falten an der Hose
vielleicht ein bisschen
Falten an der Haut
Falten an dem Oberteil von dem
von dem Sattel
deine Haut die drückt sich halt
drückt sich so rein
und dir wird sowas von der Arsch weh tun
mit diesem Sattel nach ein bisschen längerer Zeit
das ist nicht normal
so und
ich hatte am Anfang auch richtig Probleme
mit den normalen Satteln
die man so hat
bei einem Rennrad
oder einem Gravel Bike
also bei den härteren Sätteln
Satteln
aber das ist Gewöhnungssache
also natürlich erst einmal
kann sein wenn es überhaupt nicht besser wird
dass der Sattel einfach nicht zum Popos passt
aber es ist Gewöhnungssache
also wenn man sich
man muss
ein paar Kilometer damit fahren
also man muss schon einmal
1-2 Wochen mit dem Sattel fahren
immer mal wieder
und dann wird man feststellen irgendwann
ok es tut ja gar nicht mehr so weh am Popos
man sitzt bei diesen Satteln
halt viel mehr auf den Knochen drauf
anstatt auf der Haut
und auf dem Sitzfleisch
was man von diesen klassischen
gefederten Satteln kennt
und da muss man sich erst einmal dran gewöhnen
ja das ist
man hatte doch erst einmal das Gefühl
der Popos, der Arsch entzündet sich irgendwie
weil es halt dann
wenn man neu ist
und zum ersten Mal auf so einem
harten Sattel gesessen hat
auf sowas hier
und du setzt dich danach
auf einen ganz normalen Stuhl
dann tut dir der Arsch weh beim auf dem Stuhl sitzen
an den Stellen wo du halt
wo dein Arsch
auf liegt
auf dem Sattel
aber das legt sich mit der Zeit
das legt sich mit der Zeit
das ist normal
wenn du ganz neu bist
wenn du noch nie auf so einem Sattel drauf gesessen hast
da bringt dir auch die beste Fahrradhose nichts
die wird erstmal ein bisschen der Arsch weh tun
für ein paar Tage
also für ein paar Fahrten
und danach
das ist ganz normal
und das beste was man machen kann tatsächlich ist
zusätzlich noch sich eine ordentliche Hose zu kaufen
also eine Hose mit
Polster drin
mit Polster drin und mit
Hosenträgern
dann rutscht nichts
vor allem reibt nichts
weil das Ding immer ordentlich sitzt
und durch den
Polster den man am Hintern hat
dann hat man nicht nur ein Polster am Hintern
sondern diese Hosen
haben ja
wie schreibt man das eigentlich
BIP
das steht für
Hosenträger
BIP
so
und da gibt es jetzt
wenn man uns die mal von innen
irgendwie anguckt
bei Amazon
und wenn man die sich von innen anguckt
dann sind die bescheuert
warum haben die das Polster nicht da drauf
das ist eigentlich das wichtigste an der Hose
das sind ja kleine PP Gas
ja
so sieht es in der Hose dann aus
du hast natürlich dann auch sofort
so einen Bauch wenn du dir sowas anziehst
ja hier sieht man das Polster
da ist ja ein Polster
das ist auch ein bisschen persönliche Präferenz
was man da für ein Polster mag
und was nicht
zumindest hat es einen Vorteil
euer Sack
ist auch gepolstert auf dem harten Sattel
und glaubt mir
das ist gar nicht so
verkehrt
ich mein nicht
als wäre euer Gemächt eh
also erst mal ernsthaft
beim Fahrradfahren gerade hier auf
harten Satteln und in der
bisschen sportlicheren Sitzposition
es ist eh
negative Länge
die euer Gemächt da hat
also
das geht ins negative
das geht gefühlt nach innen
bei dem Druck da drauf
also wenn ihr nach dem Fahrradfahren
die Hose auszieht
ist das alles umgekehrt
ungefähr nur noch ein Drittel
so groß wie normal
und wenn ihr die Hose dann auszieht
dann geht das wieder
aber das ist eh gut
ist vielleicht auch windschnittiger dann
man macht schlechteren Sattel
und verlagert das Polster in die Hose
hä wie jetzt
den Zusammenhang verstehe ich
ach ich glaube jetzt check ichs
du meinst man macht quasi anstatt
einen schönen weichen gepolsterten Sattel
macht man einen harten Sattel
macht den
achso
ja so kann man das auch sehen
allerdings hat diese Hose natürlich ein paar Vorteile
ja
die Hose hat ein paar Vorteile
die ist erstens antibakteriell
und es gibt viel weniger
Falten
weil du die Hose halt mit einem Hosenträger anhast
wohingegen wenn du eine Schlabberhose
anhast auf so einem normalen Sattel
ähm
dann hast du nicht nur
Falten auf der Hose im Sattel und so
du sitzt halt
du sitzt ja auf dem Pobbes
und da ist ja Speck und Fleisch dazwischen
und das wölbt sich dann so über den Sattel drüber
und reibt und rutscht da drauf
ähm der Sattel drückt
dir in die Eier
weil du halt mit dem Pobbes rein singst
und dann in vorgebeugter
in vorgebeugter Haltung
das für 3-4 Stunden
das klappt nicht so gut
also es hat schon tatsächlich seinen Sinn
dass sich das durchgesetzt hat
also wenn du einen Sattel
der ordentlich dort
ja Auflagefläche hat
wo deine Sitzknochen sind
und dort wo es reibt
und bisschen Support braucht
dort hast du dann von der Hose das Polster
also man merkt das
man merkt das
naja ich mein
selbst wenn du jetzt sagst
weißt was ist alles egal was ich sage
du kannst von ausgehen
dass Profi-Fahrradfahrer
das machen
wenn es in irgendeiner Art und Weise
Vorteile bringen würde mit dem Omasattel zu fahren
würden die mit dem Omasattel fahren
ich hab auch 4-5 verschiedene ausprobieren müssen
bei Amazon
ich bin jetzt hängen geblieben
bei so einer Hose mit
die hat grüne Polster drin
ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher
vor welchem Hersteller das ist
die hat richtig schöne
große grüne Polster drin
also nicht große breite
breite grüne Polster drin
ähm
weil ich hatte immer das Problem
das die Polster zwar lang waren
aber nicht breit genug
du hattest die dann
die gingen dir so weit
hast du gedacht
Alter hab ich irgendwie ein 30cm Ding
so lang ist die Hose
da brauch ich auch kein Polster
aber an der Seite wo dann Zeug rumhängt
dann nicht gepolstert
ich hab auch ne ganze Weile
gebraucht bis ich ne richtige Hose gefunden hab
wie gesagt ich hab 4-5
ausprobiert
ja das stimmt
gibt es ganze unterschiedliche Sachen
und ich kann euch sagen
es ist wirklich gerade für euer Gemächt
sehr sehr angenehm
wenn ihr ein Polster in der Hose habt
wo
eure Eier ordentlich
weich drauf liegen
weil
da ist schon ganz schön Druck und Reibung
zwischen den Beinen
wenn du Fahrrad fährst
es hat einen Unterschied zu so einem Omasattel
es ist auf jeden Fall zu empfehlen
sich ne ordentliche Fahrradhose zu kaufen
ja und keine
das stimmt und keine Unterhose anziehen
in diese Hosen geht man nackig
in diese Hosen
das heißt aber auch
man kann diese Hose
nur einmal anziehen dann muss man sie wäschen
weil wenn ihr da mit nackigem Poppes
drauf sitzt
also hier legt euer bestes Stück drauf
hier euer Hintern
und ihr fahrt 3 Stunden
und schwitzt da rein
könnt ihr euch vorstellen
ihr wollt das nicht mehr als einmal anziehen
und ihr wollt es auch nicht
so lange irgendwie in nem Wäschekorb
oder so rumliegen lassen
weil das stinkt schon mit der Zeit
ja
aber da hat jeder
so ein bisschen so seine
seine Präferenzen
was er an Polstern mag
ich weiß nicht mehr welche
ich als letztes gekauft hab
aber wie gesagt die mit dem grünen Polster
und ein bisschen breiter die ist gut
ohne Unterhose das stimmt
und
auch ganz wichtig
wenn man pro wirken will Leute
wenn man wie die coolen Leute
auf dem Fahrrad sitzen will
die Sonnenbrille
die Träger von der Sonnenbrille
über den Helm
und nicht unter den Helm
das machen nur die Noobs
hab ich mir sagen lassen
die Träger unter den Helm
also unter das Helmband
das kann durchaus sein
die machen teilweise ganz abgedrehtes Zeug
die Profis
manche Profis
haben auch sogar den Sattel
nach vorne gekippt
dass die mehr nach vorne rutschen können
und mehr Kraft in die
aber was die machen ist nicht für uns
als normal Sterbliche
unbedingt so
anwendbar
ich weiß nicht wie wir jetzt auf
stinkige Fahrradhosen gekommen sind
aber ist ja auch mal ein Thema
es gibt auch Sachen die muss man mal besprechen
ja ok
oh Chatke
22.34
wisst ihr was jetzt angesagt ist
erstmal was trinken
und dann
Boomer müde
Bett getimed
halbe Stunde bleibe ich noch wach
aber ich klapp keine halbe Stunde mehr on
leg gerade ob ich noch ein bisschen Amazon gucke
oder irgendwie ein bisschen
Youtube Twitch
oder noch irgendeine Anime Folge
keine Ahnung ich weiß nicht
was ich mache
aber halbe Stunde bleibe ich noch
halbe Stunde bleibe ich noch wach
gibt es bald mehr Streams
ich bin gerade was Youtube angeht sehr unmotiviert
und durch mein ganzes rumgebastelt
und jeden Tag Fahrrad fahren
beziehungsweise rennen und
Fahrrad fahren
ab und zu dann irgendwie
ausgelastet
es wird aber
auf jeden Fall
Richtung Ende des Jahres
wieder
zunehmen
vielleicht nicht unbedingt Youtube so extrem
zunehmen aber Twitch auf jeden Fall
zunehmen weil auf Twitch habe ich tatsächlich
mehr Bock das ist immer so ungezwungen
der Laber stellt es einfach 2 Stunden
2-3 Stunden und gut ist
was schaust du gerade
ich bin fertig
gerade
nix
muss irgendwas neues raussuchen
ne
da zieht es mich nicht hin
ich meine ich weiß die ganzen Fahrradfahrer
fahren nach Mallorca
nein nein
ich habe
wie hieß das was war das letzte
was ich geguckt habe
mit irgendwelchen Waisenkinder die von Monster gefressen werden
wie hieß das denn
super
weirter Kram
keine Ahnung ich habe vergessen wie hieß das denn
ich gucke mir die Intros immer nicht an
deswegen
merke ich mir die Namen
immer nicht
aber die Story war im Endeffekt
irgendwie ein Haufen von
Waisenkindern in so einem
Waisenhaus
und im Endeffekt kam raus
dass das gar kein
Waisenhaus ist sondern
also Anime Story
sondern es ist ein
quasi
eine
Farm für
Monster die gerne Kinder fressen
Weird Champ
Into Abyss habe ich auch geguckt
fand ich nicht schlecht
wenn auch sehr weird
ah ich habe vergessen wie das heißt
wie hieß das denn
keine Ahnung
da gibt es eine zweite Staffel
die zweite Staffel soll aber ultra sacken
deswegen habe ich einfach nach der ersten Staffel aufgehört zu gucken
also ich gucke ja noch nicht lang
Animes
hauptsächlich bin ich da jetzt drauf gekommen
ein bisschen auf den Geschmack gekommen
weil mir die ganzen Streaming Services
so auf den Sack gegangen sind
man braucht für alles irgendwelche Abos
dann gibt es das wiederum nicht mehr auf Amazon
zu gucken sondern bei irgendeinem anderen Streamingdienst
und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht wisst ihr was
wenn ihr mir alle so auf den Sack geht
dann gucke ich mir einfach auf
naja sagen wir mal
gucke ich mir einfach auf
rechtlicher Grauzone
einfach paar
Animes an
und da sind echt paar ganz gute Dinger dabei
wie hieß das denn was ich geguckt habe
das war
das war super weird Champ Kram
mit den weißen Kindern
äh
ah warte mal
The Promised Neverland hieß das
ja
The Promised Neverland fast fast
The Promised Neverland hieß das
und nachdem ich am Anfang aus irgendwelchen Gründen
warum auch immer
hauptsächlich irgendwelches cute Zeug
geguckt habe
mittlerweile muss ich sagen
gucke ich auch ganz gerne Sachen
wo mal ein bisschen was passiert
und das schöne ist
nachdem ich quasi
vorher nie Animes geguckt habe
ich habe jetzt gefühlt
keine Ahnung
150 Jahre
die ich Zeug gucken kann
und es geht einem nicht aus
ja wenn ihr irgendwelche Spezial Geheimtipps
habt die man sich unbedingt angucken muss
könnt ihr mir Bescheid sagen
vom Ultra Weeb werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht hören
nee
ganz ehrlich wenn ich mir das anschauen würde
ich kann
ich kann mit diesem Genre ehrlich gesagt
nicht so viel anfangen
wo es dann immer abgedrehter wird
und du schon irgendwelche
Power Statistik brauchst
das du noch irgendwie halbwegs durchblickst
also wenn ich mir das angucken würde
dann würde ich mir diese
da gibt es ja so Fan Zusammenschnitte
habe ich gelesen
angucken die quasi
alle Filler und Rückblenden
und dummes Gelaber entfernen
sodass du quasi
bei über 1000 Folgen auf 370 oder so
rauskommst und es sich immer noch
gut schauen lässt
ja war auch
ohne Scheiß war bis dieses Jahr auch nicht meins
gar nicht
aber es gibt doch mal ganz coole Sachen
One Punch
One Punch Man kenne ich zumindest so
grob das kann ich nicht mal gucken
weil ich da auf Youtube
irgendwelche Best of Compilation Sachen mal
geguckt habe
da bin ich schon komplett gespoilert
weiß ich was passiert
ist aber auch nicht wirklich so
so das Genre was mich interessiert
ich weiß nicht also
was hier jemand anderes noch gesagt hat
Into Abyss fand ich auch
sehr nice wenn auch
muss man sagen
wenn auch etwas
weird champ
ich weiß nicht was
mit den Japanern los ist
aber
warum müssen das immer irgendwelche
zwölfjährigen Kinder sein
die so ultra knappes Zeug anhaben
das ist
manchmal ein bisschen sehr weird
also keine Ahnung was da los ist
ja ich weiß nicht
die Japaner enjoyen das irgendwie
das habe ich tatsächlich auch
geguckt
aufgrund einer Empfehlung
im Stream hier
oh ne hör mal bloß auf hier
das habe ich auch geguckt
das fand ich gut
wenn auch am Anfang ein bisschen zu lahmarschig
aber insgesamt fand ich es gut
naja
wie dem auch sei
ich gehe jetzt pennen
wir hören uns morgen früh
bis denn Bett getimed
machts gut see you